hello everybody oh my gosh give me a second you guys aren't
alive too on my screen I'm not alive you're not alive it's a
wonderful family hello everyone
so why are we playing oh I almost said rivals why are we
playing that's tomorrow all right we're going straight into
overwatch yes overwatch now overwatch 2 it's overwatch now
um it's a because you sound how i feel dead inside yes right
that's that's right anyway um yesterday i googled uh because
my manager made my waiting room and he was like what time it
was like 10 a.m because i was pat gonna pass out um But I
googled yesterday.
I was like, what time does the new season of Overwatch come
out?
And it was like 10 a.m.
And I was like, all right, 10 a.m.
And then I googled today.
What time does the new season of Overwatch come out?
And they're like, 11 a.m.
I'm like What the fuck
What do you mean now It's 11 a.m They got me real good They
really did I even waited the last minute Have you seen the
Elsa Bloodstone trailer yet?
Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you I assume
it's DPS so I don't really need it for Much of an opinion
for now Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It really is 2020.
We're going back to Overwatch.
We're about to do next season.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
It truly is.
2026 is my retro era.
It's nostalgic era.
It was a good time.
And then bring back Retrodokie.
We're going backwards today.
So for those who don't know.
For those who don't know.
uh uh Overwatch 2 is no longer Overwatch 2 it's Overwatch
they decide I can't believe it Overwatch is back before GTA
6 came out um and uh we're evolving backwards yeah so it's
officially called Overwatch um and we're restarting the
season so technically it's season one of overwatch now um in
an hour it's season one of overwatch um and not only that
but they are dropping five new characters to support oh yeah
by the way mizuki i think it's mizuki that's his name right
the the mizuki is all is basically invisible woman's old so
like it's it's not you don't disappear in it but it has the
um it's like a little shield it's like a circular shield and
like uh it amplifies when you shoot out so it's similar to i
mean in this and it heals it heals and amplify and amplifies
your damage type deal um um but the one that we're looking
forward to the most is the cat with the jet pack named jet
pack cat i don't even know if he has a real fucking name um
but but his name is jet pack cat and that's the one i'm
apparently to if like someone pisses you off you could like
pick jetpack cat and just throw somebody off the cliff uh uh
who fika fika is his actual yeah who like he even pays
attention to that it's jetpack cat uh yes you could actually
take them hostage i think the coolest clip i saw was like
people were doing cage matches uh with like someone will
carry a maga and then the other will carry like the whoever
his challenger is and then a maga will they would be flying
up in the air and the maga ults in the cage match and then
like it's like a it's like a flying cage match is actually
pretty insane and i saw another clip where they so the
jetpack cat took a cassidy and then the cassidy was like
it's how new and like hop in the sky it's like how you dodge
that how the fuck do you dodge a flying dead eye like how do
you dodge the hollown and like you try like don't worry i'm
gonna go behind this shield and then he fucking just is in
the air he's just in the sky you don't like aerial attack
incoming michael they get the aca super they get thank you i
think that's everybody is uh looking forward to at the
moment um um with uh with i think i think jetpack cat is
actually the character that everyone is um obsessing over at
the moment oh yeah for before i say more i need to remember
the show uh anniversary merch is out now yeah and oh yeah
bash oh yeah bastion with jetpack cat is actually like a
drone attack like an artillery strike too remember if like
bastion alts the bastion alts and then you get the jetpack
cat like it doesn't do anything but it looks like a fucking
artillery strike from the sky it looks like a fucking drone
attack or an attack chopper yeah the ac 130 and then when he
it's literally a drone attack uh air superiority yeah
old man sharko thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you does that mean we're getting a starcraft brood wars
stream in 20 whoa whoa we don't get too hasty there whoa
whoa slow down baby steps guys it's funny yesterday was apex
today is overwatch and tomorrow is rivals uh for truly uh
damn dokey you play uh wow you wow dokey you play come down
you play boy uh yes i'm gonna i saw my last x and i'm going
back to my first love and then tomorrow The new flame.
All my addiction in one week.
Damn, Jokey.
You have three hands.
All right.
Yeah, we're going through it.
Don't worry.
They all know.
They all know the arrangement, guys.
They're all cool with it.
Guys, he's changed.
Overwatch has changed.
He dropped the two.
He went back to like what I fell in love with in the first
place.
Like no letters.
No numbers.
We truly live in a strange thank you for your hard work,
Dougie.
Thank you for the super chat audio.
Thank you, thank you.
Overwatch is going to start up with a welcome home cheater
banner.
Think of the super chat, Lolly.
Thank you, thank you.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
All right, stream next week, guys.
see i can fix him they literally they changed um they
changed wait what did they change they change anron's face
well not like right away but they're going to so he is
fixable guys he knows like he knows how to change guys and i
can fix him i can do it i'll come back and then and then
we'll live happily ever after just like we promised all
those years ago all nine ten oh my god oh my god it's been
how long you know you know they're like if we're not married
when we when we're 50 we'll come back to each other i just i
was just realized because like if apex was seven years then
overwatch is like like almost dead okay but you know it's
it's like it's like that saying like oh then overwatch if we
are not settled by the time we're 40 uh we'll come back for
each other because at that point it was meant to be the
dokey's last one not many fps yet this week three whole fps
um excuse you uh marvel rivals is a tps it's third portion a
total original idea uh draw a bidro for every akasupa oh man
they give the super chat thank you thank you thank you thank
you um don't kill that not yeah not many fps this week three
whole fps thank you super chat turtle thank you thank you oh
all right let's make our schedule alive i have to i didn't
have time to make a schedule last night because after the
apex stream i think i i play too much apex and then i i
disassociated for two to three hours uh which is not it i
was just like i was like i think i played too long and i did
not oh yeah um and then so i didn't get it like i so in the
end i didn't get anything done uh uh fado thank you super
chat thank you thank you regular v2 where i hear from other
people don't guess i hear them games and their company She
is not the same.
They don't think even the super chat.
Thank you.
We got out of the basement and we're going back to the
Overwatch minds.
Anyway.
All right.
We finished Sunday, Monday, and we're at Tuesday.
Wednesday is the, I mean, they haven't announced it.
I feel like it's fine.
Like they're going to announce it in like, I'm pretty sure a
couple of hours.
But we all know what the new season is the new early axis.
So we will be sponsored to check out the Marvel Rivals Early
Access for Elsa.
I don't know what team I'm in yet.
I don't know what team.
And yet, so like, because it's not listed out.
Other than, I mean, it's sort of, it's tradition at this
point.
And today is, obviously, I wanted to try out on launch day.
Because it's the best time, like for Overwatch.
Because I felt like, you know, we all get to experience it
live.
on what changes it is an eu friendly stream too so
congratulations eu you got one this is for you uh do you get
thank you super chat thank you thank you i'll stick during
your anniversary stream so congratulations a bit late thank
you for all the good times over last year thank you thank
you super chat thank you thank you for uh wishing me a happy
anniversary i really appreciate it really appreciate um the
support uh thank you again for the super chat thank you
thank you gonna say oh yeah um so that's two when's that's
when's we're wednesday sorry i was like what day is it today
i'm losing track oh yes for those who are wondering who is
replacing coney for the pubg tournament i asked heavenly if
russian badger was down well i asked gomez to ask heavenly
uh because he was playing with heavenly if like practicing
with heavenly if russian badger was free to do it and he is
free so i've never interacted with russian badger before but
i know like he has had siege experience so and like he's
close friends with heavenly so i was like okay i'm shooting
my shot and uh and i saw a lot of people asking me to ask
russian badger when i post up the initial tweet of
recruiting someone so um i don't really personally know who
he is i know a lot of people a lot of you guys were
requesting russian badger and heavenly um heavenly responded
say he wanted to try join and then and i saw a lot of people
being like at russian badger at russian badger so um i asked
heavenly if he could ask okay i asked gomez to ask heavenly
if to ask russian badger made it a little bit complicated
there if he was free and they uh he said he is so he's gonna
be joining our team uh on on Sunday I've never interacted
with him before but uh I I you guys said that he seems
really he's a really funny guy so and he brings the vibes so
and he's really good at siege and FPS games so I trust you
guys and he seems like a really funny guy uh yeah uh I know
a guy who knows a guy who knows a guy
So he's going to be on our team.
What else?
He accidentally double booked.
He promised another obligation on that day on Sunday.
So he had to choose one or the other.
And he said the other one was like a full day.
So he had to do the other one instead.
And I think he promised that one first.
And then didn't realize what week mine was exactly.
I didn't tell him the date.
I think he just got he was like just really busy and
everything um so he didn't realize that he accidentally
double booked uh for that day uh so that's really what
happened and that's really what happened um I saw Lily's
team was actually practicing for the game my team hasn't and
then the production team was like Ducky, if somehow on day
two you do go last place, would you be interested in casting
and like doing being the interviewer and I was just like
I didn't respond and they're like but like not that we don't
believe you that you won't get last place but like if it
does happen if it if it does happen
I lost Guys, it's okay We don't need practice, guys We don't
We don't need practice We're just naturally gifted And we
could be the next prodigy For PUBG blind spot We could be
guys We could be like Like secret prod strategies that we
don't need practice guys there's no way guys it'll be last
right
there's no way who needs practice oh my god that was a bad
cough sorry i had um sorry that was a don't worry i'm not
dying i just still have my cough oh my god yeah that was a
bad one i sound like a fucking i just sounded like i was
dying guys i swear i wasn't bit guys i swear i've known i
wasn't bit guys there's no i'm not patient zero um no i
choked out my saliva my saliva wasn't doing so well in the
back of my throat uh anyway uh all right let's let's figure
out the schedule thursday we're gonna do the state of play
watch a lot and then i guess it's only one hour long i don't
know yeah i guess we could continue this ah but then that's
like two twitch streams on the row um all right let me what
the fuck is this game it just showed up look at this game
quarantine i'm gonna go outside right now you can't
quarantine me you play as tiny gnomes breaking into giant
human houses to steal stuff flood toilets prank everything
and then escape in a tornado what the fuck is this yeah this
is a friend slop game this looks like a friend slop yeah
it's the era of friend slop caper oh my god the tiny gnomes
they're stealing the panties all right anyway i gotta i
gotta fucking write my schedule guys doing my schedule all
right let me put a text real quick too put on my cough drop
and everything all right where is the text text uh add um
let's see oh no i don't know what these texts say so i don't
i'm worried about you know like um when you add a new new
source you don't know what it says so okay i'm just gonna
add a new text because i don't know what it says all right
doing schedule while waiting for new for over new overwatch
season all right
there we go this seems like a good place uh
next seat they give us super chat thank you thank you um my
oh she's gonna lose the team coughing baby that's the real
name because she's also a coughing baby oh your car feels
better today getting the super chat guys we don't know yet
guys we we don't know okay maybe only two teammates have
actually practiced for the game and sure force just been
playing deadlock and i also have been playing every other
game but pubg blind spot but but we're gamers
we're gamers anything can happen
it will be fine we have we have the natural instinct you
know we have the the reaction time that's built in our soul
we'll be fine i'm literally practicing my reaction time in
every other game and we'll be okay
gamer nation rise up all right let's actually make our
schedule for all right what did i do anything on no i didn't
do anything on sunday okay um making schedule time if i
could i would share this but like i i never like shared i
never shared photoshop before so i'm always like nervous i
i'm like super paranoid of stuff i like testing things out
before i share anything on screen so so um i i always worry
i will actually dock something like my files or some shit
all right let's see what do i on monday sponsor apex legends
ah where is it sponsor apex legends season 28 there we go
season 28
All right, that was what we did.
Oh, actually.
Let's see.
And then we do subtitles.
I am so out of it right now, guys.
I was not ready.
New season and 28 early access stereo.
all right no 10 a.m.
is it's too early i'm not i'm not a real person until 12 30
p.m that's where that's where like my body realizes like um
overwatch is when my body was like hey it's time to be a
person all right let's see all
right and then
new season one five new jet pack cat is out there yeah i
like i oh my god it's so crazy i write new season one the
fact that they like restarted the season
to one i guess like we actually reset the clock
it's insane it was all a dream yeah hey once a whole fresh
start it's so confusing like what about the old they deleted
my overwatch one history to be like we gotta get a fresh
start in overwatch to just to go back to overwatch one and
i'm like my top 500 history is gone what was it for why why
did it delete my history then to delete my and for what why
did they remove me they removed my my stats and just from
Overwatch 1 just for it to go back to Overwatch 1.
They removed my presence.
It's like I never existed.
Oh my god.
Daisy, thank you for 10.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
Okay, Overwatch.
And then...
sponsor y'all the great thing about how every wednesday is a
rival sponsor is that i can just i can just put the same i
can just i don't have to write anything new but actually i
do it's because it's a special stream all right marvel
rivals uh sponsor and then is it on twitch with drops there
you go uh all right thursday state of play watch a lot oh my
gosh okay i need to grab another state of play watch a lot
special stream no uh there you go state of play oh yeah
there's not just new hero but five new heroes guys five new
characters two take that's our two supports two dps and one
take i like how nobody has talked about the other dps
because they were all focused on like onron and who even is
i already forgot who the other dps is no one has like gave a
fuck about Overwatch, new characters.
Like, who?
Everyone, oh, yeah, the guy.
The one, oh, wait, the, okay, I was going to say the one
guy, but I forgot Mizuki is also a guy.
But, like, it's, yeah, it's Soldier 78.
The other guy, no one, I felt like he's just, yeah, the evil
soldier said, I'm you, but evil.
He's literally...
He's literally like anti, what was his name?
Anti-Fla- Anti-Solji.
What was the guy?
Reverse Flash.
Reverse Solji.
It was me.
It was me, Barry.
What was Solji 76's name?
It was me, Jack.
That's right.
It's me, Jack.
Okay, you know what's...
I still can't believe they killed Doomfist on February.
I think that's...
I was just like, whoa.
I'm just like, that's like...
That's a very unfortunate timing.
Yeah, it's wild, yeah.
He just fell out of the window.
He shouldn't be fine.
Apparently, he's like, he's apparently dead and killed by
Vendetta.
He's going to come back.
They're not going to be like, we're just going to delete
Doomfist off the roster.
Like, I mean, a lot of people will be very happy.
including support players and like finally he's dead no
longer no longer i will have to go against doom fist and
also that is true there's no fall damage in overwatch so how
could he die
and then like okay so the current lore is that vendetta took
over talon talon or whatever and like um and he killed she
killed the doom fist was the leader of talon and then she
killed doom fist like she pushed him out of the window which
is crazy because like people were like how the fuck like
she's like how the fuck did like doom fist die to her when
he literally like one v'd for a tracer winston um and genji
and hanzo like everyone's like wait that how the fuck he was
gonna blink and then Vintana comes in and pushes him out of
the window what is this like what is this the Russian
assassins who somehow for some reason every time they try to
someone mysteriously dies in Russia they get pushed out the
window like don't you don't use no too much don't get near
windows don't you're not supposed to say that out loud but
anyway uh Allegedly, allegedly, allegedly.
They're all natural caught deaths, by the way.
They just have, there's just a lot of clumsy people in
Russia that just happen to stand behind windows.
Allegedly.
Anyway, so the sole store is that she, anyway, she pushes
him out the window.
He's, quote unquote, dead.
Ombra and Widowmaker leaves Talon, um, and be like, peace, I
guess, like, oh, no, Talon lost your biggest money maker
because Blizzard gave them all the skin.
I don't know.
How will Talon be funded now?
Reaper and Widow were literally the money makers of Talon.
Oh, no.
That's your essay.
Thank you, Miss Super Chat.
Thank you.
I saw JDK fans slandering, Doomfist, and Sower.
take him out the roster and rework him thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i mean they did take fuse out
of the roster i still don't know why they took out fuse guys
he was there for 30 minutes i was about to play him and then
he's just gone yeah i know yeah apparently the reason why
reaper left was because um he killed her dad he killed
vendetta's dad so he was just like oh
and Widow left though I guess Widow is just like I guess
Widow is just like we ride or die bro we Widow and Samba we
ride or die I guess Samba was like I help my fellow Latino
Yeah he thought it was gonna be awkward you know like
obviously she was gonna kill him if he stayed like I feel
like yeah if he stayed it's gonna be so fucking awkward like
like Oh yeah, well Sigma is not forgotten.
He's literally crazy.
Like he doesn't even fucking know what the fuck is going on.
It's not like he's forgotten.
He's literally like so, so insane that he doesn't even know
what the fuck is going on.
Like if you tell him there, God, he's not gonna register and
he's literally crazy.
Like the numbers got him.
He's just like, the numbers!
What do they mean?
Like, the numbers!
It literally got him.
Who's, who's Doomfist?
Yeah, he's gonna be like, who the fuck is Doomfist?
Alright, I'm almost done with my...
I'm not streaming on Friday, guys.
Too many streams.
I might do double streams on Thursday, because, like, I
don't like that as two Twitch streams, so I might do an
extra bonus...
Chill stream.
Maybe I'll do a good night dragons on Thursday with the
state of play.
And then Friday I take the day off.
And now Saturday.
It's Dad's birthday.
Okay.
What was the hashtag I used for it?
Uh.
Does anyone remember the hashtag I used for my dog's
birthday?
FGO, they even super chat.
Thank you.
I can go.
I can go overdrive.
Look at this.
Maximum overdrive.
She died.
And someone, can someone bring me and my hashtag for my
dog's birthday it's my dog's birthday yippee that's my dog's
birthday yippee oh happy birthday okay all right let's put
that in happy birthday amber 20 26 you know what we'll do
dad actually no it looks ugly okay amber i think amber is
fine happy birthday the thing is hashtags don't red don't
recognize periods it's my dogs it's joki amber doge's
birthday birthday yippee i don't know it's my dog's birthday
it's oh whoops that's my dog's burr it's my dogs dad
birthday yippee all right okay it's happy birthday hashtag
happy birthday number 2026 okay doki doki doji birthday
that's too long that's too long i'll just do that i'll just
reuse the same one and just add 2026 it's the easiest all
right putting down the dates and times now eight uh 14th
it's nice that it's also a saturday that's nice eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 i have plans on next week by the way like
next week I'm I exist next week I just hope to exist all
right we're gonna have good night we'll have good night
dragons uh for Thursday um FGL they use super chat thank you
thank you don't worry that has something very special plan
oh wait I should I just realize I have no God of War.
We'll play God of War on Thursday.
I just realized I was like, oh shit, we gotta make progress
on God of War, guys.
We have to make progress on that game.
I do not want to be stuck on God of War for like half a year
like last time.
I just realized that.
I was like, okay, it's up.
Good night, dragons.
We'll play God of War.
makes more sense it'll be very unfortunate to be stuck on
that game bum bum where is my god of war fucking text here
i'm just trying to find this oh there it is so i don't have
to sign this copy and paste i mean it might be easier if i
just write it um i can't be bothered guys
bottom what ragnarok there you go added in what's happening
i am making my schedule for this week because we are waiting
for overwatch to update because they pushed the release time
to 11 a.m instead of 10 a.m so we're gonna we're just
chilling until then 20 more minutes 20 more minutes guys
wait is my food here i haven't eaten yet oh my god i could
have eaten before too wait oh my god my food's been sticking
sticking sticking my food's been sitting out for 20 minutes
can you say i'm gonna grab my food i
got my food yeah food time
Wow, she doesn't look well.
I didn't, I swear, I'm not fit.
Oh my god, don't even have a straw?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, do I even have straws in my apartment?
Alright, it's fine.
I don't need a straw.
Life is just, life is about adapting.
I'm here to adapt to the world.
Bro, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to say this.
It's not tweet about it.
But apparently, after the Super Bowl, 500 private planes
flew out of the state of where the Super Bowl was.
And then we can have plastic straws.
Like, what's the point?
500, no, 600, I'm sorry, I was 100 short.
Like, oh my God.
600 private jets, by the way, private planes blew out of the
state of where the Super Bowl was.
But we can't use plastic straws.
Oh, we're the problem here.
We're the fucking problem.
think of the environment and I bet three of them is Taylor
Swift's private plane
you guys hear about that like Taylor Swift literally flies
on her private jet like every fucking week not even every
other day
she literally just flies on her private jet like if she's
like I gotta get my hair done I'm gonna fly to this other
state it's fucking wild
that she should my queen but you want her to use her legs
you're close to the truth you monster you freak you want her
to walk how much time 17 more minutes it's actually crazy
that they let that happen they they refuse to let us have
plastic straws for this this is what my straws died for my
straws died for their sins
walk now i don't know what to i'm trying to find an artwork
to use you know what i'm gonna use I should know I'll use
that one for a lunar new year
picking the right artwork for this you know what I could use
you know I'm gonna use my my cover my music video cover
stuff for it I feel like it's appropriate I haven't tweeted
out my music video stuff I
believe I'm no strong I saw my god it's
okay I got coffee too
all right did it hit 300k not yet but thank you guys so much
for the support i did not expect it to do that well i really
appreciate it guys thank you everyone for uh for having the
huge support where is it okay there it is who wanna um free
wallpapers by the way free wallpapers of the um of the uh
music video stills if anyone wants to use it for a wallpaper
all right let me grab this i'm almost done my schedule just
in time for overwatch will the cover ever go on spotify i
won't look into that i'm just lazy i just have like a 20
million things to do so like i've always wanted to but i
keep like stalling because i have so many other stuff to do
that i keep forgetting i keep forgetting to look into it
i've just been so busy but one day one day okay
I mean, I see a lot of covers.
I see other people always...
I see a lot of people uploading covers on Spotify.
I think it's possible.
I just don't know the process of it.
Like, I know that Amalie uploads a lot of covers on Spotify.
So, there's clearly a process to get it done.
I just don't know what it is.
I can't believe they didn't give me a straw.
I'm so sad.
life is so harsh all right let me i'm just putting the times
now guys we're almost there we're almost at the finish line
and then we can play and then overwatch will come out wait
what was the oh my gosh i got i was like where's my calendar
my google calendar all right so see 2 p.m pst 2 gst uh that
was 7 a.m gmt 10 p.m
uh overwatch i'll just put technically okay 10 a.m 10 a.m
pst a.m a.s t.s t that was guys when what time is state of
play guys does anyone know what
time is state of play i don't trust google no more guys i
know it's on thursday but what time is it
is it also 2 p.m god everything is at 2 p.m today is it i
feel like oh my gosh everything is that tool.
8.10.
8.m.
I heard like it's an hour long, so people are saying that's
the longest day of play.
Like people are like, oh yeah, and state of play tends to be
not that long, so there has to be a lot of cool updates.
Will I fall for it again?
Let's find out.
We're gonna find out.
I'm gonna fall for it again, guys.
gonna find out
one hour two games free fight someone make the edit now and
then it's like that tweet where they're like we're so sad
that this person is gonna the what was the other lady in the
files is gonna get assassinated died by keeping herself safe
tomorrow someone pre-fired fell for it again we're so sad
that don't keep it fell for again tomorrow yeah
because one of the other lady in the files the one that's in
jail um she was gonna go on she's gonna go on she was gonna
go on trial or something like the next they're like oh yeah
she's gonna go for a trial next tomorrow and people were
making like memorials for her Like in advance and we're
like, oh man, I can't believe.
I can't believe her cat, like, I can't believe she kept
herself safe again.
Oh, yeah.
You're like, you're like, we remember her.
But it's like that.
Fell for it again tomorrow.
It's not even tomorrow in two days.
We remember Jockie falling for it again.
tomorrow all right 6 p.m 2 p.m 6 p.m do i do god okay three
four five six that's four hours that's three i'll do it at 7
p.m we're doing a late night god of war stream we're gonna
do 7 p.m so i can have like rest between sata plan uh 3 a.m
all right 7 p.m god of war stream on thursday jst oh that's
12 p.m yeah that's on thursday and friday i'm piecing out
i'm fucking recovering from my coma but then see you thank
you the super chat thank you thank you why your motto looked
like a beverly hills girl tried being emo after final she
has left out a will and is like was it called is it called
gossip girl oh my god that's the throat when when did gossip
girl come out or like easy who's the other one i know your
your secret song pretty little liars i look like that the
girls from pretty little liars because i'm pretty and i lie
I actually read the books before uh true Dragunis Quill
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you don't
forget the lie aspect I actually read the books before
before it became a popular TV show it was very interesting
it was very interesting and then I for I didn't realize how
fucked up I was also like you know really young when I
should not have been reading books but it was like you know
like when bookstores because i used to go used to go to a
bookstore a lot and um they would put like bestsellers and
pretty little lives was like bestseller and then i was
definitely way too young to be reading those books i because
like you know i was like oh my god that's so that's so oh my
god forbidden love and i was like oh my god it's no no this
is and that's get oh you know it's like like I won't explain
what was the forbidden love but what there was a forbid
there was a forbidden love for some apart and for those who
know the pretty little live series I was like oh my god
forbidden love and then as I got older I was like this is
this is illegal I was like this is illegal
um no way oh dear forbidden forever no it was I can't say
exactly and I can't say exactly what was really bad about it
about the premise but if you read the books you know why you
know what as in breaking the law yeah truly forbidden it's
actually illegal but in the books when like in the books
it's like not passed off as like it's really bad so like
it's so like it didn't seem like it and then you know when
you get older when you realize how bad that is you're like
oh my they did tone it down in the tv show the thing is on
the tv show they toned it down of how actually illegal it
was and then but like in the books it's even it's a lot
worse it's a lot worse like i mean like her parents should
call the fucking fbi he should be on a list why are there's
why is he not on the list why
oh my god okay then
oh that kind of legal anyway it became a very popular tv
show with a very catchy opening i should really love the
opening what is it called anyway she made millions of
dollars from this from her books got a secret beep it turned
less than insane
yeah it's it's a really i find i think the song The song in
the opening.
It's really good.
Alright, I finished my schedule, I think.
A little off-topic.
I have to say the primal Doki plushie was top tier.
The golden combinations were endless.
Maybe with Doc Shirt's missed opportunity.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We are not bringing her back.
She's gone.
The Doki Prototype 1 is God It's like Kill me Say goodbye
Say goodbye to Doki Prime
Prototype 1 It was our failed experiment We We threw it in
the dumpster Doki name bring her Back She's okay I
legitimately don't even think she's she's exists anymore But
if I somehow get a copy of her and I sell am I doing auction
of her would at people actually bid on this would be
Primordio don't keep that I would That she's actually lost
media Oh
Bro it would sell thousands I'll talk to I'll talk to my
distributor and see I'm most likely auction it for charity
most likely
okay I've ever read pretty little liars if you read it now
at your like at the age we are now you guys will realize how
fucked up that book was but then like it was like geared
towards like young adults slash teens and tweens and stuff
and i was definitely way too young to read that but like the
fact that it's geared towards i feel like it was even too
young for teenagers and tweens honestly like the premise of
the book like the drama in it was definitely like because
like like you know i didn't register how fucking bad that
book is and the book is like pretty messed up when I like
processed it as an older as an adult when I processed it and
I was like remembering the storylines um oh yeah and there's
incest in there too they're like there's it's like because
like the the spoiler alert from what I remembered um like
she had like a brother like like the girl that supposedly
died but she faked her death and then like they were like in
like the brother really really liked her like his sister a
lot and yeah that the yeah the pretty little liars is like
pretty pretty bad and it was geared towards teens and tweens
it gets really i don't even remember I don't I personally
don't remember like what happened um what happened I don't
remember exactly like um the entire story of pretty little
liars but I remember the ah forbidden love I remember the
really fucked up parts because I was like
yeah I was reading I remember when I read it I was like oh
and I would keep up to date with it i had like i think i had
like seven of the seven of the hard copies because you know
like when the books first come out they would be hard copies
um before they get pulled into because they're like the
special edition hard copy copy cover books um because
they're like the first releases and then after the first
release the second release are like paperback so i would
have the first release hard cover copies of pretty little
liars because i was like oh my god what's gonna happen next
like you know you're like oh my god like he is actually
alive oh my god oh my god it's so juicy and then as an adult
i realized wow that book was pretty fucked up oh my god that
book was wow we're currently conducting a live main testers
you may need to restart your game okay i need to restart my
my battle net you're doing a live maintenance right now the
present no no it's okay it is like a murder mystery but like
but that was like that was like plot b that was actually a b
plot i know it's very surprising but the murder mystery part
was a b plot the the a plot there were several a plots it
was all about like all the girls random love lives like love
lives no that checks out yeah all right let me see if it if
it's out now all right let's see i restarted my client and i
don't have a notification yet now
all right in queue oh my god i'm in queue only 90 players my
god nani players have a better pc than me or running like
dual pc setups or some in q all right while we're in q i
actually need to pee i'll be right back
80 players wd me thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it was oh sorry i think i need to tab up w bite
size solid alan Okay, I finished my schedule.
I'll post it after the stream.
Schedule done.
I'll read it out for you guys.
It's tomorrow is Rivals Sponsor at 2.
Thursday, State of Play Watch Along on Twitch.
Rivals 1 will also be on Twitch.
God of War.
7 p.m.
on Thursday.
know stream Saturday will be my dog's birthday at five and
then Sunday and Monday will be three will be 3 p.m.
PUBG tournament that's the schedule I post all of this post
all of this after the stream yeah update time I can't wait
to try jetpack cat that's the one I want to try the most all
right let's see I'm gonna take a bite out of my food now.
This birthday.
Um, is that the wrong launcher?
Oh no.
No, I updated the client.
I did, I swear.
Why does it still said Overwatch 2?
No!
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Why does it still sink too?
Oh my god, now it's updating.
Okay, thanks Overwatch.
Okay guys, it's updating for real now.
That's crazy.
90 people are waiting in the wrong line.
um 89 people were waiting in the wrong line chap 89
guys i got out of the queue
okay i'm already done downloading the two gigabytes not even
two gigabytes like 1.29 i was wondering why i had the two in
there i was like maybe they'll deleted live like they're
like Overwatch and then when you're in the queue they like
remove the two it's a little special cinematic or some shit
where they like where the two just disappears
alright there you go up there we go now I'm 200 there you go
now the two is God that looks right now
look at that the two is God oh oh
it's okay maybe 200 people will have their game crashed
maybe there'll be a power outage in one specific city and
then I'll get in I
just need to find out which city has the most overwatched
player and then something's gonna happen there's no way it's
gonna take two hours guys don't say that don't say that
there's a bunch of drops not not today i feel like the
launch is so special it should be on the main channel
i know everyone's like super excited though or because it's
like you know i heard like when they announced the five new
characters um overwatch like they oh my god there's so many
people streaming overwatch right now but when they first
announced the um i'm seeing people on overwatch 2 screens
not just me it's not just me that fell for it people but i
saw a lot of people um a lot of people were like uh were
like really excited about the um about the new character
drops that like apparently player player bait like the
player count like peaked um like times five what it usually
is because everyone was like super excited coming back to
overwatch because of the because they got rid of the two
they got rid of the two and everyone's like oh my god the
game i fell in love with is back the two is gone guys No
way.
I mean, it's the fifth most popular game right now on
Twitch.
That's already, that's a lot.
Oh my god, Tim is not any players in queue.
I swear to God.
Of course, of course the partnered streamers have priority.
It's crazy that Tim wasn't in the priority queue.
Of course, of course the partnered.
The partner, the partner Overwatch streams get nepotism.
But you see the people who are actually in, in right now,
and you're like, of course they're in.
They got whitelisted.
Coincidence, I think not.
I don't think it's a coincidence.
The Overwatch darlings got in.
at least 200 players i don't at least it's not 300 at least
it's not 300
that's that's fine by me the one percenter strikes again
classic one percent hey i'm 300 yeah that's right it sucks
to be you that's not true i saw some streamer got 300 that's
not true so in the end as long as i'm not that guy i saw a
streamer was 300 so i'm not at least i'm not that guy i've
no idea how long this takes by the way it's been so long i
remember I don't remember.
It's been so long that I do not remember how long this takes
But it doesn't look like it's coming down Can you confirm
I'm also at 300 came here to see you play but you're also
stuck in camp It's because I fucked up.
I was waiting in Overwatch 2
I'm a hundred
We did it we're 100 now we need music because i don't know
if i have music for us we have this what i do some happy
music while we wave progress we're moving up in the world i
can't if i play the cover i get copyright strike arbor
levina is making money off my cover
how about this guys I give us a goal if the cover hits a
million a million I don't know that's a way too much 800k
I'll aim for 800k if the cover hits 800k views I'll release
skater boy I'll do a skater boy cover
three 500 we're at almost at 300 I feel like 500 is feasible
Say less Time to Lower the map I already lowered it from a
million I took 200k out back and shot it 800k If we hit 800k
I'll I'll work on a skater boy cover Hmm
come on 70 players we're almost in we're so close yeah the
two is actually gone no 800k viewers on the cover the cover
or itself wait why did tim oh wait i was gonna say oh my god
is tim in yet oh my god tim is in i still can't believe
we're back this season I just think it's fucking hilarious
that like we're back to season one is it's so like what dude
the numbers don't matter no more the numbers never mattered
the meta is switched to Asia and relaunched yeah but I don't
want I yeah but like I want to play in NAQs I don't I don't
want to play in Asia Qs I'm gonna get so much pain
They never mattered.
They just wiped me out of existence as if, like, I had no
impact at all.
What's the word?
Like, they just wiped me off.
They snapped me out of existence.
As if, like, my achievements never existed.
There's a word for that.
Oh, my God.
There's 30 more players.
Please.
I just need 30 players to have their PC crash.
I got the zero in it.
Don't say that.
It's not gonna fail.
It'll be fine.
Don't say that, guys.
It's not gonna crash.
Oh
my god, six players!
We're almost there.
We're almost at the finish line.
2.
Oh my god.
I'm tapping back in.
2.
Zero.
Come on.
Do something.
Searching for game server.
Entering game.
Oh my god.
It's here.
Entering game.
Oh.
All right, this is where this is where they kill Doomfist.
Is that Doomfist?
Okay, no, it's not.
I was like, oh my god, Antonio.
Who's this guy?
Oh, her dad!
It's her dad!
Reaper killed him, by the way.
It doesn't really help with the happy music, by the way.
You're so happy.
But now you're gone.
And they've taken everything.
You have gathered us all here for ends.
Get to the point.
We should have put a stop to Vendera a long time ago.
She's a threat.
I've been tracking her for years.
She's gone from nothing to...
to this.
She's building up to some...
She's building an army.
I'll see if I can turn off the beach.
There you go.
You've saved me the trouble.
You're all here.
Ah, Nartia.
What an unexpected pleasure.
You're not welcome here, Ven.
I've earned my right to be here.
Paid for him blood.
But what have you?
I mean, that's what a shadow...
Shadow organizations are.
Oh my god.
Don't stand near the window, Doomfist!
Don't do it!
Don't do it, Doomfist!
That's how they got him!
Don't get closer to the window.
Bro, Vendera, your DPS do something.
Noofus, no, you haven't been DPS for like seven years.
And they said Like a coward, you bear
I'm here to take it back You deserve nothing Power is not
passed down It must be seized It's the same guy that was
able to predict Tracer's blinks by the way Yeah but back
then DPS, guys.
They slowed him down when he got into a tank.
Because he had to buff up.
He had to swole up as tank, guys.
He lost his speed.
Yeah, he got old.
He's slower.
Look, he takes that, though.
He did.
He did his job.
You disappointed.
me so close to your vengeance and now you hesitate it makes
you weak I want to remember this moment I need where are the
heels more is not here but more is AFK
Don't worry, there's no fall damage in Overwatch, so he'll
be fine.
Not the window.
It's okay, guys, there's no fall damage.
He's gonna be fine.
That Moga's like nice.
Oh, wait, there's Mora.
And the world will kneel.
A new Talon Empire.
begins now the reign of talon that's cool though that's sick
like we're at the villain arc now don't stand by the window
that's how they got him we're done
we're done monkey
enhance enhance Overwatch, battle stations.
We are under attack by...
Yeah!
Sombre, oh, good.
Okay, is this...
Oh my god, is it okay?
Is it...
What the fuck happened?
Sombre, Sombre Orchestra Music!
Alright, five...
It's a rave, apparently.
The Sombre Rave.
all right five new heroes jetpack cat uh mizuki bro even her
fucking artwork is so different like i like how i i like how
even her fucking like this artwork is not even like the same
as the as the one the in-game model updated look and feel
the revamp ui Overwatch, yeah, so this is weird.
It's so, it reminds me of like, it reminds me of Fortnite.
Oh my God, the Hala Kitty and Friends.
I don't know, oh, Ultimate, what is the Battle Pass anyway?
New Empire.
Oh, so during her initial, Sojourner recognizes the threat.
She won't back down until the job done.
Oh, I guess like, it's like, um, they restart Overwatch, I
guess.
Uh, oh, yeah, it's in Hong Kong dollars because I made this
account when I was still in Hong Kong.
Uh, I want to see the battle pass, so like all of it.
No, not legal, that document.
I don't, because my account was made when I was in Hong
Kong.
So like, oh my God, the cat skin.
Oh my God, she's actually, she's actually a fucking drone.
holy shit oh the battle pass let's see i'm actually curious
what's in the battle pass oh my god zara actually getting
something that's crazy what's this oh that's cute oh it's
the new tracer skin all right the new mora oh whoa mora i
mean you
all right mora let's see what is this there's the bab skin
the cat i will say best cassidy skin now buy 100 loot boxes
for an epic oh my god back in the day everyone doing like
loot box openings and stuff uh thank you the super chat they
get that everyone was trying to do back during the olympics
um when the olympics uh collab came out and everyone was
trying to do like the loot box opening for the genji skin
for the japan genji skin remember that oh my god lucio
actually getting a skin what is this i'm actually surprised
lucio actually being recognized i don't know i don't think
i'm not a fan of these skins i am uh yeah people were
fucking upset oh yeah and then i i thought it was so funny
that mercy players were complaining about their mythic skin
even though it's their second mythic skin is people were
like oh boo um your mythic you have two mythic skins and
you're still not happy like
now i play graphics on their greens yeah people were like
you have two how can you still not be happy the green
that's crazy how much are they 69 off nice i will say i
think i think the pom-pom purin is cute i like the pop okay
what are the oh my god what
cinnamoro is actually canon in the overwatch universe oh my
god they're actually of course there's mercy Kiriko of
course there's mercy Kiriko and Juno they know that the
three supports the three supports gets the fucking highlight
intro only those three characters that never get that never
get play of the game it's actually crazy you know they want
sell more if they give it to like diva or widow because at
least it's more easy to get play of the game or even lucium
if they give it to lucium widow or diva it's easier to get
play of the game to actually see these highlight intros
because like I know it's very unless you're like unless
you're playing like DPS Kiriko you're not fucking getting
like I rarely ever see highlight like of the game for any of
these characters.
Mind me, stop.
And even then, Lucio, at least he can get it for boops.
At least he can get it for the fucking boops.
That's fucking hilarious.
That's why they allow you to see the intro right now.
Nah, he doesn't.
It's literally only a Kiriko, Juno, and Mercy.
what's this cute dance oh my god this is so fucking weird
from widow maker like they're like we have to give widows
something it's so out of character oh yeah it's so funny i
don't know if anyone saw the new the season 27 apex charm
but it's literally like very um it's very like poppy girl
coded because it's like a heart like the new the new season
27 like predator like apex predator charms is literally like
magical girl coded and everyone was like what the it came
out if they felt like it came out of nowhere the gun charms
this is 225 us dollars is that no way wait how much is how
much is this how much is this currency because mine's on
hong kong dollars how much no there's no way don't fuck with
me there's no way how much how much is all of this in in
american dollars 6 900 minus hong kong dollars guys okay
this is cute though oh my god i just sort of want this i
actually it's like 70 okay 60 all right oh my god if it's
not on oh my god i just realized i no richard price is 223
oh my god if you try to buy this post launch okay but i sort
of want this though i sort of want the icon though all right
you can't lie this is pretty cute actually not nice
best cinnamon roll recipe oh my god wait carol carol p every
day is fun oh that's cute that's cute don't do it but but is
she the model it's my oh she that's 28 per skin by the way
it's 28 but okay i would just buy it not gonna lie i would
just buy these these four wait what does it come with no i
don't care much about pom-pom i um i think pom-pom purin's
cute i would just buy oh i would buy just a cinnamoro one
not gonna lie i would just buy the cinnamoro one just so i
can have the icon i have 13 days to think about it guys i
have 13 days to think about it before i do regret anything
before i don't fuck but get get toky camp and never fuck
It's a limited collab.
It will always be on sale, Doki.
It's a trick.
Thank you for the saver chat.
Thank you.
What else?
What the fuck is this?
It's a souvenir.
Oh, yeah, I can summon her.
It's summon the cat or some shit.
But, but is she no more?
They know what I want.
They're toying with me.
They know.
they know what the fuck oh my god this is so weird just as
they planned all along this is so weird i don't know if i
like that it's so tiny all right there she is there's domina
there's that baddie right oh my god what the fuck
oh my god holy yeah she knows she's a baddie too
whoop whoop what's heartbreaker oh damn damn the fact that
it went but it was bottom top too
this is who emma frost wish she was not gonna last salty
Listen up.
Is this the mic drop?
Oh, it's a universal.
Okay, it's a universal emo.
Okay, I was like, that looks fucking weird.
Oh, they reused that.
That's unlucky.
I wish they didn't reuse that.
Let's see.
What do they have?
Shall we negotiate?
Oh, that's what she sounds like.
I wish it was a little deeper.
He's stuck there.
What a capital idea.
She's so posh.
Oh my god.
Just expense it, darling.
Oh, darling.
I wish she rarity.
What is it, darling?
Oh, you'll soon regret that.
Yeah, I wish her voice was a little lower.
Welcome to my world.
Oh my gosh, literally rarity.
I just realized.
Even like the hairstyle.
She's so posh.
I saw some oh oh wait that's fucking sick crimson wolf wait
how do I unlock this okay I was worried that I'll act that's
actually the red gun is actually sick obviously glow gold is
the classic I saw someone with the galactic gun but I didn't
think it was that cool I think the I think the I think this
one is sick though no you can't unlock it yet
Jetpack hat.
All right, Jetpack hat.
There you are.
That's so dumb.
It's actually a fucking...
Five by five.
They have them to be orange.
The aviators, too.
Danger zone.
Oh, yeah.
I heard in the practice range, you can control a little
laser pointer.
uh a laser pointer and stuff for him well how does it look
like with the cat oh i can't i think he's not allowed to
hold a mic okay oh they don't have it they're like what let
my cat mic drop i demand to let my cat microphone drop let
him say his thing
so literally unplayable honestly no let him hold a
microphone literally unplayable my cat can mic drop what's
the point me having to equal rights for the cat i swear to
god wait wait if hammond can if hammond can mic drop then
like oh yeah see look okay Wait, actually, I think it has to
be the character.
Where is Hammond?
I need a note.
If Hammond can mic drop or not.
My god, they're just racist.
No rights for cats.
It's unfair.
He can mic drop but not, but not my cat.
Wow, Blizzard.
All right, let's see.
Apparently someone's like, check out that voice live.
That's discrimination.
That's just a volume, okay?
Can you guys hear this?
He's spinning.
He deserves to be able to mic drop.
It come up a little bit.
All right, I'll do that.
That's Ashley's voice.
That feels crazy.
Actually, it's sounding out of here.
Let me know.
So I need to, I think, I wonder if they reverted my
settings.
Options.
Nope.
It's, oh my gosh.
Wait, even this looks different.
Oh, it's so weird.
I'm not used to it at all.
New 400.
I don't think we're going to get there anyway.
This looks a little different.
It's like taller.
I don't know.
Doesn't it feel, like, taller?
It feels taller.
Ah, Mizuki.
He's a guy, by the way, for those who are wondering.
We're, like, unsure.
I mean, from this, you can tell he's a guy.
From this, it was hard.
This was harder to see.
Because of the haircut.
And, like, he's covering half his face.
People were, like, not sure if it was a guy.
girl because like also the outfit too like this guy was like
you know he's got it you got to show yeah yeah and then and
then like period this in the air you're like oh yeah it's a
guy it was it's a
guy he can mic drop this discrimination towards cats what
does it sound like What the fuck?
Wait a minute.
Don't jinx it.
Be gone spirits.
I brought the salt.
You should count your blessings.
Got a problem?
You're starting to annoy me.
Hey, just a little bit like Genji without the filter.
Yeah, doesn't he?
He sounds sort of like Genji but without the depression.
we're like kindred spirits doesn't he everyone's got
something to hide yeah like if he was Genji wasn't depressed
he sort of sounds like yeah about the depression and the
filter all right we got Mizuki and then Aaron they're gonna
change the face by way for those who don't know they're
gonna oh the way it's a panda okay that's cute they made her
into a furry that's her persona guys i can't believe her fur
skin she made her into a furry
but they're gonna change the face oh my god she's wearing
sneakers too i just noticed that uh but they're gonna change
her face to make it fit more like her cinematic what's this
oh that's Because it's literally just Kierko's Kierko slash
Juno Meh I will say this one's pretty meh Like she can mic
drop Why can't all the other characters mic drop?
Where is a spark diligence over talent Yellowfish is yeah
The grind never stops I'll burn brightest.
I don't know if that's like, I know Faria, Faria voices
asked her.
She was like, she's an Overwatch content creator.
She basically made it.
She basically made it because she was like, she was just an
Overwatch content creator and then she became like a
cosplayer who cosplayed official stuff for people and now
she's like now she's a now they and they picked her they
picked her as the overwatch voice actor for our honor and i
think i think like i i will have a little critique for it
but she's doing her intonations english intonations instead
of unless like i'm wrong but it feels like because like
there's no questioning tone in chinese intonations so it
feels like she's she's doing a lot of english intonations
for the chinese for the mandarin but i'm not sure if that's
just me because the ma sounds a bit weird because you're
supposed it's like dip down right I remember like You know,
you know, you know, it's like more More down Instead of
Instead of like up So like I could tell That's why I was
like playing it You know, you know, you know, she tones it
up But in In like, because like in Chinese We have set
intonations So she's supposed to go down So you know, you
know, yeah not sure but i'm not sure i haven't like but like
i'm not like super fluent in mandarin but i got i got like
made fun of for my intonations when i speak cantonese um
because i use i use the same tonations as her when i'm
speaking cantonese and they're like and my friends would
like make fun of me being like you're why are you using why
are you using like these tones yeah because like what are
you up to now
sure i'm not sure if i'm right or not because i'm not fluent
in uh uh i'm not fluent in mandarin i just knew in cantonese
i got my friends would make fun of me because i used the
questioning tone um i used the but it was just that that
voice that everything else was like so cool but like it was
just this one ayah you guys gotcha because that's how i hear
because That's how my, that's how my, my, my relatives use
it on me.
I, I only feel, I instantly recognize it because I've had
that said to me a lot in Mandarin.
So I was just like, oh, my relatives would say, use this
tone at me.
And you guys got some more.
That's why I kept listening to it.
I was like, it sounds weird, right?
It's a spark.
It sounds...
A core memory.
But yeah.
But yeah, good for her though.
She's like, she actually made it.
As like an Overwatch content creator leading up to becoming
actually in the game as an official voice actress.
And we played Jetpack Cat Bros.
This is why we booted up the game.
We're here for Jetpack Cat.
All right, play.
We do...
I do quick play.
Support.
That's so weird.
That's so...
Oh my god.
Wait, that's the tab?
Oh my god, that's so weird.
Oh, I forgot Emory.
But to be fair, everyone forgets Emory.
I forgot the, I forgot anti-soldier 76, but everyone forgets
about him.
Everyone forgets about him.
Like, who?
Amber sucks, bro.
I'd be on my villain arc, too.
I don't know.
Am I?
For the fluid matter in.
speakers am i is it is it can you say can you say it in the
upper tone so are we when are we gonna ever starting the
game because i want to be educated with the jetpack where is
he oh nice nice he wants missuki and i want jetpack cat it
depends on the car so you can tone it up right because i
I've heard it more toned down.
Nice.
You could?
Oh, okay.
So I was just...
I was wrong.
Okay, how do you play...
I didn't read any of these.
By the way, I did not.
I should...
I should read...
Wait, let me...
Alright.
A cellar in your...
I should have went to the practice range, guys.
A cellar in your movement...
toggle the transport mode allowing ally increases what's my
oh wait what is it dive towards knocking down enemies and
tearing oh my god okay so i oh my god okay wait what is my
don't worry guys i'm heading over oh i'm just waiting to
grab oh my god wait the cooldown is so fast to grab people
that's okay this is my zoom
Oh, I should start healing.
I should really heal.
Don't worry, I got you.
Don't worry.
Who did I grab?
How do I grab?
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to figure out how to grab properly.
I'm sorry.
They don't give us their lookout.
Give us their lookout.
gibberish looking up oh my god it's because he's a cat it's
a cat
oh they have to accept the grab we got cats oh
okay he was getting healed he hit okay to be fair that cat
hit me like 20 times before i registered he was shooting at
me guys you have to remember the cat He shot me for so long
until I realized he was shooting at me.
Did he miss?
That's it.
Cat fight!
Oh shit, I should have paid.
I should have healed.
Oh my god, none of them wants to take my cat!
Wants to take my cat thing!
Nobody wants to take me!
What do I do?
Don't worry, I got an idea.
Where, who do I?
I'm trying to figure out how to grab people.
Quick melee becomes empowered every...
Gate up to...
Okay.
I don't think that's a good.
Wait, I want to grab someone.
I
got it!
I got it.
Don't worry, I got you!
It's so...
Don't worry, I got you, girl!
Get by it!
This is so dumb.
I think I love...
I think I...
I think I like hit my cat.
That's right!
Oh my god, my bullets are paused!
My bullets!
Is it by?
Area strike.
They'll never expect the cat from the sky.
Okay, maybe they will.
What the fuck?
Come on.
Accept my carry!
Why would he accept it?
Oh my god, I'm gonna shoot the cat.
I'm going for you get the cat get the cat that's right I win
the cat fight
freaking damage here cannot fight an impact when flying fast
enough I don't even know which is good I'm the better cat
bro nobody wants to accept my grip I don't know why
Do they not trust me?
See, like that's not fair!
Not fair!
Get over here.
Get over here!
Cat fight!
Right off the better cat!
I'm the better cat.
I would not accept.
Why does no one want my grip?
I don't understand.
The cat diff.
The best cat twins.
Cat diff.
Okay, I think a jet pack hat is really fun.
No one wants to let me grip.
Why won't they let me grip you?
Cat grip.
Let me grip you.
I don't understand.
How you did, bro?
Okay, guys, yes.
Actually, let me go to practice range because I'm like a
bit.
confused.
I'm about...
Alright.
Okay, I need to look at the perks.
Actually...
I think...
Like, I don't understand.
Why don't they want me to grip you?
Come, accept it.
Accept.
Can Friendlies accept this?
Take the grip!
Take it!
They don't let me take the grip.
Alright, let's...
Quick melee becomes ruining enemies for destroying them.
Quick melee?
What the fuck is quick melee?
Oh!
They just gave me a new ability.
What the fuck?
I literally get a new ability with this.
I don't have that before.
Yeah!
This is a new ability.
Pyrrhic can now damage nearby for 50%.
What the fuck is Pyrrhic?
Pyrrhic can now also damage nearby enemies for...
If you can knock back an enemy...
Okay, wait.
What is my...
Oh my god.
I need to remember.
This is not rivals where I actually have to go in here.
Okay, what is Pyrr?
Okay, Pyrr is this.
Okay, this knockbacks enemies.
Okay.
Uh Pure recovery.
Okay, so basically So if I do this And then I go like Wait,
why can't I knock you?
Alright
Okay, that's useless That's, I'm sorry, but that's useless I
don't know if that I guess it's your Insta Lucio not Okay,
that's a Lucio boop, I guess.
You can use that as a Lucio boop, but I feel like that's a
little useless.
All right.
I want to see Mizuki.
How do I heal?
Is it just this?
No, that doesn't heal.
Ah, my hat.
All right.
But it's funny, though.
I have health regeneration delay.
Throw your hat, bounce on nearby healing you when it
returns.
Launch a chain that hinders the first enemy.
Oh, I have passive AoE healing.
Oh, I do.
Oh, so it's like Lucio.
Yeah, heals nearby healing skills with resources generated
by dealing damage and healing.
So if I do enough damage and healers.
Oh.
Inbind, a paper doll reacted to return and gain increased.
Okay.
This one is a little more difficult than a flying fucking
cat
This is a little more difficult than a flying cat Someone
says, is she new to Overwatch?
Let me show you Does this look like I'm new to Overwatch?
If you recognize that icon, then you'll know the answer
Alright all right let's see uh leave forward leaving behind
well the thing is i was like a quick melee but i don't have
an ability for melee and i realized by picking that perk it
gave me the ability for the melee so i was like confused uh
leave forward leaving behind reactive rate to return and
gain increased speed launch a chain that hinders the first
okay so it's like a rival rival thing is it what is it i
guess like are you not able to move after that i wish i can
just select it i don't have to go back yeah i guess like
okay base tank what does it t there would they be stuck i
guess they'll be stuck i guess uh leap forward and all right
and then oh all right that's interesting do i do you can you
see me when i'm in that Oh, oh!
Reacting, oh!
Okay, so I can just like, I can go in and then just beat
that.
Is there a timer?
It is a timer, so if I don't do it, I have to...
Alright, I see.
And then I don't need to look at my ult, because like, I
know what the ult does.
And then...
Okay, that's cool.
Can I press F1?
Oh, I can!
here okay yeah about to hold it all right what side of my
perks hitting remedy aura resource generation is increased
by 25 hitting enemy increases your damage dealt to them i
guess it depends if you won't be aggressive or defensive i
guess healing bounces one addition each bounce increases
when callus returns active allies with and is increased
increase i feel like while katashiro's return is active So,
like, if I use this, everyone has increased movement.
That would be good if I'm, like, trying to be super
aggressive.
I mean, it seems cool when I want to be super active.
Boop.
Alright.
So that is his ability.
Alright, what are the others?
Domina.
Alright, Domina.
Construct a segmented barrier, push enemies back, stun them
when they hit a wall, project an explosive, and reactivate
to detonate it.
Dealing damage with abilities, restore shields, reduces,
fires a hard like that imprisons enemy and detonates on
expiration.
Oh, wait, this is tracking.
Oh, that's fucking easy.
It's like tracking and I guess like hit scan, right?
Okay, is this projectile or hit scan?
Let's see.
How far is the range?
It's not that far.
So, like, yeah, you have to...
Okay.
It's not that far.
I wish your voice was a little lower, not gonna lie.
I did not expect this voice.
Yeah, it feels like...
It does feel like Ultron's gun.
Yeah, it is Ultron.
It doesn't feel like it is.
But it's easier because you're not flying the fucking air.
It's easy.
the easy version of Ultron's gun because you're not in the
fucking air while trying to control that.
True, because you don't have to go like up, down, left,
right.
You just have, I guess you have crouch, but that's it.
I almost forgot you crouch here.
Let's see.
What is this?
Oh, so that's the detonation.
And then there's my shield.
Oh, okay.
There's the shield.
Okay, I have to, like, time that, though.
And then that's the boop.
I feel like this is hard.
Yeah, okay, this you gotta be able to time that correctly.
And there's my barrier.
I would fuck around with that.
I would fuck up that, too.
Yeah, they dropped five heroes at once.
After using barrier, restore 50 shields and active passive
health regeneration.
After using restore 50 shields and activate passive.
Okay.
Increase the range.
If I want to be...
Ah, that's hard.
After Restore...
It's like, this is...
Left is playing for the team.
Right is playing for me.
This is...
I don't care about the team.
There's me getting health charge.
Alright, what's the other one?
Enemies hit by crystal charge are slowed for very mused as a
wall is stunned enemies.
With a one-weight.
Oh!
Oh, that right side would be like a skill thing.
I feel like right would be a skill thing to work on.
Because like being able to time the barrier is like an Emma
Frost thing.
So being able to time the barrier and then using the Sonic
thing on it.
And it hit his fire.
So this one will be easier to do on paper.
Oh, on paper.
on paper there you go and then you slowed on paper indeed
all right the youtube's plush oh the youtube's plush is live
guys so you guys want to get what the official watson x
dokey bird plushy is now up on youtube thank you for the
super chat w thank you thank you I and then I think I played
Oh wait that's vendetta Sorry this is Onrun I think Onrun is
Onrun seems fun to play She seems very strong Like this and
then Oh my god Imagine doing this And then the E I feel like
that's such a strong combo Wait I'm gonna try it I feel like
shift then E would be a strong combo And then Yeah, that
that's a strong-ass combo What is the right?
That didn't be too close for that.
Yeah, I do She seems very she seems very strong like I think
the shift e combo is really good It's really scary in
general I think that's a scary combo Like if I do this And
then Like I feel like if I can get that off that would be a
strong ignite burn Can anyone use your ultimate for each
enemy ignited by it?
Oh my wait, that's so p I'm gonna go right right seems
fucking OP as hell Heal 50 help for each heal 50 help for
each what?
Wait, okay, what does that look like?
All right seems wild doesn't it and then that's my shift
right oh my god okay that's that's scary all right the
forgotten man the one that no one remembers the anti-soldier
soldier 76 reverse soldier temporary wield a semi-automatic
pistol with life-stealing spills move faster and Jump higher
when wielded.
Gun guy number two.
What is Call of Duty?
The other's battlefield.
This is battlefield, man.
Throw a grenade at the enemy shortly after bouncing.
The fuck?
All right.
Transforming you into a living weapon.
Oh, is this a Punisher?
Three round burst weapon.
To hold the zoom in.
Tightening accuracy.
Increasing fallout.
This is battlefield, man.
Yeah.
We have Call of Duty, man.
Now we have battlefield, man.
Oh, he's...
Halo Man?
Nah, this is...
Oh, this is Halo Man?
Alright.
We finally have Halo Man.
Your grenade.
Passive regeneration after your sooner and still restores 30
health when activated.
Alright, let's try them out.
Okay.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Okay, okay.
So... Oh, it's fast reload after...
After... Yeah, that's fast.
After you shot your gun, I was like, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Yeah, I know.
This is Halo, man.
No, the...
I see the cyber frag?
Yeah.
Alright, let's see.
Hold to zoom.
This is definitely...
I'm playing Halo right now.
I'm...
all right overall light round slow enemies by whoa okay
siphon movement speed bonus is increased by while not firing
i don't know i feel like what's override protocol override
put oh okay so that's where yeah i feel like that for my oh
would be pretty strong there's less fall off damage when i'm
like zoomed in apparently it does remind me of bastions too
the gun direct hits with refunds heat okay cyberfrags oh
yeah sticky oh yeah wait is it not sticking where's my stick
now stick building 40 to stop what the fuck i swear i threw
it at him is that not sticking would that not choose oh my
god i didn't choose i didn't choose it the wrong perk give
me a sec i got refund
all right let's refund this real quick that's my bad i was
like wondering why it's not sticky i'll be this more
upgrades there we go okay that's i mean technically oh yeah
that's that's op all right what is the queue what oh my god
i can fly What the?
Okay, now...
Oh, that's scary.
The fact that I can fly with that.
The fact that I can fly with that is very scary.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, is this like...
Is it by clicks?
They fly now?
They fly now.
Wait, what is this?
Is this by click?
By the way, it's by click and you know I a fast trigger
finger.
That's what my usual trigger finger.
Yeah.
But that's just my trigger finger though.
You guys know I can press my left click really really fast.
I have a really really fast trigger finger guys.
It's different.
This is like my, this is me using my normal.
speed get the other me time to get that auto click crazy I
am my own macro exactly I'm my own macro all right wait I
need a no I okay I didn't see I forgot about this guy all
right let's see new Empire oh yeah that's that one we saw
that before Mike drop pharmacy jetpack cat any tank with
guns soldier 64 let the chair force begin patria has to
think of the super chat thank you thank you john halo yeah
john halo looks really fun he really does where's john halo
for him let's find out look who's back for more top lee
aiden wait wait that's i know this language i know it open
sesame oh my god that's a road i won't go down He sounds
like Scandinavian, right?
Oh, he's Irish.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I was like, it's Irish.
Because that, okay, never mind.
He's Irish.
Oh, he's Turkish.
Okay, we're all wrong.
We're all wrong.
I was so off.
I was like, I'm scared.
I was like, wait, is that?
Because he's like, it sounded Swedish a little bit here.
I was, this part sounded Swedish.
I don't trust easy
I clearly did not know I was so wrong guys I do not know my
European geography I was like it's Gaelish I was like that
does not sound Gaelish how dare you keep up the good fight
it's worth it alright so he's Turkish I was like it seems so
familiar but I guess I was wrong.
Alright, let's try out...
Actually, I sort of want to try out John Halo.
We'll do John Halo.
I want to check him out.
Yeah, I'm at Gaelic.
Oh, yeah, I don't watch, like, any of the promotional
videos.
I just go in, like, live.
I experience it live.
I just don't want to like spoil myself.
Hi, thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All right, where's where is he?
It's so different to our level one level one Oh, wait, she's
level six.
We're all babies I'm like, we're all playing a new character
We do it live
right little babies we have jetpack cat and you pick mercy
it's like mercy but you're in the air forever there's a cat
on a jetpack i'll put it all on the line
i can't believe it okay at least we have someone that's
jetpack cat we have a cat that's literally on a jetpack and
you still pick mercy
what what happened
oh my god why can't i have that why can't i wait a minute
that's not fit shoot the cat shoot the cat shoot the cat
Why is no one shooting the cat?
Oh my god.
Okay, I need help.
Oh
shit, tabbed out.
This is awkward.
I actually accidentally tabbed out.
Am I the only one that's shooting the fucking cat?
Am I?
Someone shoot the cat.
Oh my god.
he's solo oh my god he's solo i'm so sad wait siphon speed
i'm gonna do that
oh my god oh my god stupid mate
i swear to god i feel like i'm just doing damage
I did it I
fucking did it I killed the cat
Oh my god I fucking did There we go There we go The cat's
dead The cat is dead The cat is dead I feel like I'm the
only one looking at the cat oh my god he's so low
i'm gonna push the cart i'm gonna be a good cart pusher
there's no one else gonna all right i mean sure i mean sure
oh my god he's so low i'm so sad i'm so i could have killed
him i'm Where's he upped it?
Oh, that would have been a...
I would have got a really sick-ass kill there.
I use this to, like...
Oh my god, I don't remember the map.
I also sort of...
I hate push maps, to be fair.
I'm not...
I literally went the long way.
I learned the long way.
I forgot what this map looked like.
Where's the cat?
I forgot.
There we go.
I will go!
The cat!
The goddamn cat lives!
I swear to God, I feel like I'm the only one shooting the
cat.
I feel like I have.
Oh my God, where the fuck is the cat?
Where is he?
Oh my God, this is stupid fucking me.
Yes.
Holy shit, she pushed me back.
Oh my God, please.
Oh, you're crazy for that.
Your fact that you're still alive.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Please, please.
I'm so close to it.
I will kill you.
I will kill this cat.
If it's the last thing I do.
The cat's dead.
I did it.
I told you, I will kill the cat.
It's not the cat.
Cat down.
I repeat, cat down.
Cat is down.
Uh-oh.
Rising from the ashes.
Are you feeling more powerful?
I hear him.
This won't take long.
Hey, what the?
Oh, shit.
Why me?
Where's the cat?
Enemy's got the robot.
Let's change that.
I swear, see, guys, I swear I am literally the only one
shooting him.
Like, I don't think I'm...
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm so fucking dead.
Run, cat, or what?
I'm the only one that's doing anything.
Gamers, don't look up.
I swear, I just need one more person to look up.
And then we can kill the cat.
We can kill...
I just need one more person to look at him.
I'm the only one that cares.
I got him.
I got my one.
I think we might lose.
I think...
I got my one.
Looking up is hard.
Apparently so!
Apparently he is.
Yeah!
We won!
I feel like I did so much damage, but like not kills.
final blows play of the game i feel like i spent all my time
just shooting a cat
yeah it's five and five i don't understand why is it why is
my cat frontlining and their cat is 200 miles away and yet
i'm the only one that's trying to kill him i i felt like i
was the only The only one making an attempt to shoot the
cat.
No one else wanted to shoot him.
It's fun.
It's literally like I'm playing Halo.
Across the universe.
I don't want to play OpenQ because OpenQ is just hell, I
feel like.
OpenQ is too chaotic for me.
I like to have some system.
You know, some...
I like it.
when games have like some form of control and system in
place uh instead of pure anarchy
i don't really like the anarchy part of it yes some some
form of control yeah apparently with the weight a little bit
the joint oh my god wait actually i want to okay after this
game Let's make, I don't want to play, I don't know.
I don't like playing tank overall.
The only tank I like to play is Zarya.
I don't like playing shield tanks because it's just too many
buttons.
But I'm going to make a custom lobby after this game, so get
ready, guys.
And then it's all cats.
It's all jetpack cats.
It's all, we're going to have, we're going to play Ace
Combat.
Is it Ashley Forever Frozen?
Last time it happened, it like slowly, yeah.
cat foot
oops all cat
honestly jetpack cat is so fun but i know like it's fun
because i'm doing quick play i feel like i feel like if it
was like um if it was rank i will not have fun with jetpack
cat because i feel like at that point at that elo people
will look up people actually will shoot the cat down
feel like like I will not live in the sky at all it's like
playing ultra you have to be like super cautious oh my god
do I just restart or just leave game I'm gonna leave game
does it seem like it's gonna start all right let's queue up
again that's UI is so weird I'm not used to it versus join
talent or join a fucking course i'll join talent oh but then
all the cool kids are god uh wait jetpack cat is on
overwatch oh my god it's 50 50 as it should be okay we let
me see what the rewards are project jetpack cat wait but
jetpack cat is on overwatch though oh that's so hard
Oh, man.
Do I join evil or do I join cat?
It's not even over.
I should just cat.
Are you telling me the cat is cat over evil?
The cat always wins.
If cat always wins, why is it 50-50?
Are you kidding me?
Second time in a row?
Really?
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
Second time in a row.
Let me play the game.
Oh, okay, I'm in.
I'm in.
Oh, there we go.
I had to get it before I don't trust.
Mercy.
You can be a cat on a jetpack.
and you still play mercy you should no next update will be
for rivals we're bringing the dog from space i won't be
surprised to counter the cat that rivals will release the
dog the was it the dog from space and rivals yeah i gotta
show off the new myth i swear if you don't have the mythic
skin oh my god she does wait she has the she full bot the
wait is that not the mythic skin at the last level is that
not oh yeah cosmos is that not like the full the full like
yeah this person literally just wailed the last uh the last
option for the new mythic skin holy how much did you pay oh
my god how much
again and you oh my gosh i swear i'm not i'm not peeking
instantly because this is a widow map that's crazy oh my god
people are already doing movement oh
my god that's fucking right
stereo jesus wait holy fuck
okay this this character is broken as hell i will say holy
okay no they have to nerf her i don't know what i was just
pressing buttons and i killed everyone like i think she is
absolutely broken not gonna lie she 100 i
think she's broken just from me saying doing that
Oh, it's five.
I get heals here.
Oh my god.
I actually have to think playing her.
Oh, please, please, please, please, please.
Save me.
No!
I actually have to think, though, when I play her.
Like, I actually have to, like, think about what I'm
pressing.
She's like...
No, she is absolutely...
Yeah, like, no, she's very broken.
Like, I don't know what the fuck I'm doing, but, like, I'm
doing a lot.
Like, that should not be a thing that I'm doing right now,
you know?
Like, I gained!
Oh my god, I gained!
I already got an achievement!
there you go like holy fuck i do not
that's i do not feel like i'm gonna back away from that
goodbye
goodbye i do have to think though I have to think when I'm
playing her Oh shit goodbye Goodbye No she has to be nerfed
She should be nerfed I don't even know what I'm technically
Doing but like The fact that like The amount of stuff I can
do With her Is like not fair This is like Absolutely broken
like I Personally feel like I don't know what exactly I'm
doing, but like I know enough to like make an impact, you
know Like that shit is crazy like that's just me pressing
like different combos What is this cat doing?
She's just in the skybox
This cat a cat is just in the sky box like i'm this cat i
don't even care
i'm not going to go in yet oh wait okay holy fuck i burned
so fast okay that was that was very cocky of me i really i
was like don't worry i can live that okay i i can't live
that i still have a ways to go The fact that I have two, I
think that's the crazy part.
I have two of that, I think.
Like, I don't think that should be a thing.
There we go.
That's so broken.
No!
That's okay.
I have my Phoenix on!
Whrrh!
it can fly back up i have my phoenix
no adran that's me not knowing what the fuck i'm doing like
50% of the time on adran but like holy shit she is
absolutely fucking broken no that it's actually unfair how
she she is like too strong she is actually way too strong
it's actually crazy like her like i said did you see like
the combo i did the shift and e the shift e the run into
them get the burn and then like e and then all here like
like people like i did so much damage for that alone yeah
she's actually so crazy broken like the shift e combo is
insane i feel resets every patch i just played what do you
mean i can't even see my history from the last game i played
you
just delete people yeah but i know the thing the combo i did
like they were in the everyone super low while in the Mizuki
alt because I did a shift e alt combo and it literally like
negated the entire support alt.
Lira, thank you for the rate.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
We had a good stream.
When you're... Otherwise it's in history.
Yeah, I try to go to history, but then they were like...
Nope.
I want to try Mizuki now.
I want to try Mizuki.
And then we try.
I don't... I'll play it.
Oh, I forgot!
The custom room!
Alright, after Mizuki.
After Mizuki, we'll go into her custom room.
It's been fun, though.
I'm actually having a lot of fun with the new characters,
but then I feel like... I do feel like the moment I get into
Rek, I will not have fun anymore.
I feel like the moment...
The moment I get into Rek, it won't be fun no more.
oh my gosh just push i just use this for speed what is my
range anyway i don't know what my range is i don't see
that's not fair it's not fair
stupid okay that's my
oh wait There you go.
Sorry, I have to remember the... Oh my god, they killed our
cat!
Okay.
Oh my god, I can't do anything about it.
I can't do anything about it.
Okay, Mizuki is hard when nobody's bunched up together.
Like, I will say, our cat our cat left us.
He was for some reason frontlining.
Playing Sombra in quick play.
I don't think our...
I think our cat is struggling, guys.
Don't worry, my presence is here to heal you.
Like, this is all I can do.
I can just stand next to you.
Oh my god, even see him.
Who the fuck plays Sombra in quick play?
There's so many funny new characters You play Sombra Oh my
gosh, I went to the left I bounced to the left by accident
Holy shit, my damage is crazy though For this There we go I
can't kill the cat!
Oh my god, not me.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
The amount of...
I panicked off the...
I thought there was more of them.
I panicked off the that.
This cat is just diving.
I keep thinking I have to like hit him.
But like I just need to...
I need to remember that.
I need to remember.
I need to remember my left click that's not here.
Holy shit!
Man, I'm out.
Holy shit.
I keep trying to heal them with my sight.
I'm like, don't worry, guys.
I can heal you.
I'm flying high noon.
It's not fair.
I'm so used to healing, like, shooting equals heal.
I just want to do that.
The barricade is moving along.
Okay.
I need to like be careful here.
Where the fuck?
I'm trying to like...
Oh, I wasn't sure exactly.
Jesus, this is so weird.
I don't know, Mizuki is so weird to play in general.
I feel like...
God, he's so weird.
He's so weird.
Like, his heal is, like, very dependent on your other
teammate, I feel.
I'm just not used to it.
I didn't, like, not waste his projectile.
I don't like his projectile either, too.
Not a fan of the projectile.
Not very good at it.
God's right, what you gotta do now?
Oh, my God, I almost died.
That's right.
Oh, that's our cat.
Like, it's slower than Kiri, I feel.
I don't know.
She feels slower than Kiri.
IMO.
Don't worry.
You got the hat.
Wait, as active allies.
He found.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is good, but...
Oh, my God.
See?
I'm like fucking...
Oh my god, he's doing it.
He's doing it.
No!
Someone shoot him!
He's in the air!
I don't know that.
I don't know.
I'm not a huge i don't know he feels weird he just feels
really weird to play in general yes interesting movement
tech i will say his movement is very interesting
i'm dead though i'm so dead i went for it
i was just stuck there let's change that like he can't even
he has no he has no mobility I think that's what's it his
only mobility is a shift so I'm not really his only mobility
is actually his shift so like I don't know it's also he's
very like the skill ceiling for him is pretty high like like
that that's my only mobility but it's not like a lot in
general like the fact that my my my It's passive, but it
feels not a lot.
Or passive?
If you get what I mean.
It doesn't feel a lot.
For the amount of heals that I could be doing.
That makes sense.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I thought my thing, my left...
I legitimately thought my left click was the heal.
I thought...
I'm sorry.
I was left clicking my heal, but I wasn't.
The aura does feel really weak.
Are you?
No!
He gets me out of everyone!
Really?
He randomly picks me up!
You know you can't control it?
control it by the way for that the fact that like oh my god
he actually got me it's always me i'm always
it's always i'm not watching it anyway i hate i don't like
missuki i don't like i don't know i think you could play if
you're really i think if the i think he's just gonna His
left click feels so fucking weird.
His projectile feels weird.
It's, like, slower than Kiriko.
The fact that he picks the closest one, and I'm the closest
out of everybody.
Um.
He...
He feels very comm-specific, but he feels...
His...
His heels feel so slow.
His heels feels incredibly slow in general.
So...
And he's not fun to play.
I don't think the...
I don't find him fun to play in general.
Because I don't feel satisfied even when I hit somebody.
Like playing Jetpack Cat was fucking fun as hell.
But like, Mizuki just felt...
I don't know.
He just...
He's definitely hard.
I mean, you could say skill diff.
But like...
He feels like...
Like me existing heals people.
but it sucks when you're looking at them and that's all you
can do yeah and like I feel like I feel like obviously it's
like damage wise it depends on your damage so I have to do
more damage but it's so hard to do damage on Mizuki because
I don't understand his projectile speed I think like I feel
like yeah but Lucy is more fun Lucy is very fun to play I
think like Mizuki is just not moment and I but like each of
the character I played like but like each character I think
like like jetpack had fun playing on on run I had a lot of
fun playing Aaron and run at air oh my gosh I don't even I
can't I remember his name what's his name uh emmer emmer I
had fun playing currently Mizuki I don't have fun playing
Mizuki he's just he's just like I don't know like he is hard
to play Like, maybe if I get to know his projectile speed
and his playstyle, I'll have more fun.
But as a first-time tryout for him, I'm having, like, a hard
time playing this guy.
Because, like, also, like, yeah, like, God, goddamn cat.
He's so weird to play.
The goddamn fucking cat, though.
Yeah, it might.
Yeah, you need another healer to do a hard...
heart but my cat was fucking flanking so i was the main
healer what i feel like i should have been i feel like
jetpack cat is i mizuki feels like a flex support and
jetpack cat is more of a i i'd be like oh my god i'm feeling
am i i'm feeling oh my god he does not care that the he does
not care at all that there's five new characters
custom game i just figured we stopped domina we'll just do
domina and then we'll do the custom game the perfect world
is shaped by my hair just wants to be junk right why that's
why junk right gets all the skins shall we his fan base is
very dedicated yeah
i don't know masuki definitely if i know his projectile
speed i definitely will have more fun but he was so hard to
play it's so hard to do damage in general
Okay, he felt incredibly hard to do damage he also lack of
mobility like I guess like the shift is his mobility, but
still The lack of mobility fucking fucked me up
What's my shift boom push okay never mind that didn't work
To be fair we do have I'm just gonna cap.
I'm just gonna cap it.
Alright, yeah, I think on this map itself is like literally
the junk rat map.
Get that cat!
I see he's going.
Get the cat!
Wait.
The tank left!
That's crazy.
That's crazy that the tank actually left.
Oh.
I have if I saw on the ground and that makes sense actually
that makes sense if it's on the ground
Oh my god, it's crazy I
mean, I'm just waiting you're not coming over so like I
don't need Like what do I I don't have a job right now my
job is
Oh Don't worry.
I still have this I see you I see you can't run away I see
you jack-back cat there you go that's a little sad get the
cat get him oh I see you
Can I?
Just hurt.
There you go.
Worth it.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Push!
Oh my god, two more players left.
Dude.
That fucking cat.
Hmm.
That's right.
Get over here.
I just want to see something.
Oh, I don't have my sprays behind it here.
Wait, I forgot.
Do I even have?
I haven't even got my first perk yet.
Yeah, I can't do stream remote because I need to win 750
games.
That's the love.
They love cats spotted.
I'm sad.
I can't.
show you guys my sick ass skit my sick ass uh sprays i mean
we literally have a junk rat one trick we have someone
that's not learning a new hero today he's literally like
everyone's learning new heroes and he's literally just here
what the fuck what get out of here oh no oh no Then kill
their cat!
I had...
Get out of here!
Where's my team?
I win it off as a poor girl.
After restore and active.
No, I'm getting my fucking...
No one... Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're all playing their characters now.
That's not fair.
My entire team...
That's right, cat.
I have a new...
I was going to sit.
I was like, that, that's not a pro.
Oh my god, you stupid cat.
You actual stupid cat.
My cat is stupid.
Please excuse my cat.
Get out of here.
Like, I'm trying to take for us, guys.
I really am.
But, like, I need help here.
Oh my god, he's slow.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I tanked for so long Guys it might wait what what count guys
it might mean I need a counter swap what calendars Ramatra
It sucks.
I don't have like actual I don't have actual movement tech
for this.
This is the worst part
I can try fucking oh my god oh my god okay I don't know if
I'll live in here but
I pushed him oh my god someone kill the cat I'm shooting him
why is it always me my cat sucks my cat sucks
My fucking cat is a loser.
All right, one counter is Ramatra.
Every time.
I hate my cat.
Guys, one counter is Ramatra, guys.
Maga?
I've never played Maga before, Bob's right.
Wait.
Okay, that's that.
All right, there's that.
All right, okay, I've never played Maga.
I think my allergies are active.
Fuck this cat.
Once to be... Okay.
I'll try.
I never played Maga before.
Whoa!
Okay.
Oh, the cooldown is fast.
Wait, what the fuck?
The minion can just walk.
It's just walking.
Wait, why are we fighting here?
Oh, that's awkward.
How did my team already die?
Like what?
How did my team die already?
Excuse me?
Oh my god!
What?
My team is actually useless.
Oh, use both?
Oh, I forgot to use both.
Oh my god, double click.
Okay.
I don't think using both guns would have saved us
regardless.
stupid cat
that's my bad that's my bad
okay I did not know I'm having break a shit look I'm
learning manga this is my first time on manga I felt like I
made it okay I felt like I made it on the platform but
clearly I was wrong that was very There we go, there we go.
I don't know.
I don't know why I clicked.
I don't know what I clicked, though.
Our cat is so dumb!
I'm sorry.
Our cat is actually so dumb.
Our cat is so stupid.
If you saw what I saw, he is so fucking stupid.
Oh, thank god, it's not me!
It's not...
I hate our cat.
I don't know, I'm chewing.
What the fuck happened?
Our stupid fucking cat.
Oh my god, who are they fighting?
It's the cat.
guys guys i need the cage match right now
kill the cat
oh so close it was so close guys it was so close i almost
got him i'm
a fucking prodigy i'm a prover watch prodigy I'm actually a
I'm her I'm him I'm literally an overwatch prodigy right now
I'm literally what's my character art I am him he is her I
fuck this cat their cat was better than my cat there i had
to counter pick because this wouldn't play domina all right
how dare you not mirror my domina where was my domina mirror
all right let's let's do a custom lobby i can't believe it I
had to counterpick.
That was literally my first time ever playing manga.
I mean, you can sort of tell.
I literally jumped off the cliff because I didn't know there
was a ricochet.
I didn't know that existed, guys.
To be fair.
Oh my god, this is the perfect.
This is actually the perfect jetpack cat map.
Just manga things.
all right heroes hero roster none
where's jay jetpack cat so nobody can counter swap limit uh
mode
wait let's see it it should be a team death match we should
have team death match okay how do i Off.
Off.
Uh.
No disable, because we're all just gonna be cats.
Off.
Oh.
Wait, it should be a team death match.
Off.
Okay.
Wait, team death match or regular death match, guys?
Should it be team death match or free-for-all?
Guys, which one's better?
Team or free-for-all?
Free-for-all team?
We'll do team and then free-for-all.
We'll do team first.
Alright.
Team.
And then...
Alright, how do I open?
Okay.
Everyone!
Jet...
Jetpack Cat.
That's just... That's the name.
Alright, map.
It has to be... Okay, none.
And then I feel like Ilios is the perfect one.
Is it Lighthouse?
Is it lighthouse or ruins?
That's the better.
Which one's the best?
Lighthouse?
Wait, not lighthouse.
Which one's the best?
Oh, well.
We could...
Well, so we could drag them into the pit.
It's like a little crane machine.
We can actually crane machine them.
Cran machine the cat.
Alright, here we go.
It's literally cats only.
I wonder what character I want to play today guys what
character should I play oh there's so many choices there's
so many things to pick from
All right.
Meow, meow.
Get the cat!
Get her, God!
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Save the cat!
Save your fellow cats!
Five, five, five.
Oh my God.
I got you.
That's right.
Get scratched!
your fellow cat I got you that's right oh you think you can
oh shit meow also heal your fellow cats no I got him I'm a
hero I
got you Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Cats got his cat.
Wait, can I pick up another cat?
Oh, no.
Remember, you can heal your fellow cats.
Get him.
He's so low.
Got him.
Oh, my God.
He missed.
Remember, you can!
You can pick up your fellow cats if needed!
Remember that!
Oh my god, we all have to think...
I can't pick them in mid-sky.
Guys.
Oh, when you can!
You can't!
I learned that you can indeed pick them up mid-sky.
Who would have thought?
No!
Guys!
we're losing the cat war we're losing the cat war
oh I got you I got you I'm healing you I'm healing you they
can't kill you oh my god
oh my god he ran away like a pussy oh my god Their cats are
simply stronger.
They're more coordinated.
Men.
Oh my god.
Men, we have to work together.
We're split.
Yes, cats.
We're split up.
Guys, get together.
Focus fire.
Focus fire, cats.
I can get in the pit.
Get it.
No!
He saved them!
He actually saved this fellow cats oh my god he saved his
fellow cats that's crazy you save this fellow cats when did
i not get that no oh my god not me not me oh my god not me
quick v formation what a catastrophe i'm here
It's not fair.
He has a skin!
He had a skin!
I demand a replay.
Check his computer.
The new Star Fox looks so good.
Meow.
Alright, guys.
Alright, let me in.
Alright, new lobby.
This time it's free for all.
that setting now to do it again don't even i should have
saved it all right free for all that's be an easier way than
this i should just need a cat
uh off disable off there you go and then map all right what
other what other good map what other map is good for uh oh
my god necropolis maybe there's a lot of i feel like
necropolis would be pretty good i need a necropolis it's an
it's an night stray it's d day we're gonna storm the beach
i'm not if there's a beach map we i would do that wait is
there a beach map we don't ah if there's a beach map we can
recreate d day more like c day cat day we could recreate it
but we can't we don't have a beach map
there is kind of a beach map which one no we'll do we'll do
a night a night raid um general none jet pack cat all right
jet pack cat and that's good jet jet pack cat everyone
all right it's a free for all so more people get joined too
save the preset i don't know if i'll be doing another i
don't know if i'll be doing a jetpack cat dick.
Wait, you're right.
I can throw...
Oh my god, you're so right.
Wait, which one's the traffic one?
Wait, that is so funny.
That is actually pretty funny.
We just throw them into traffic.
Which one is it?
Which one's the traffic one?
We pick them up and throw them into traffic.
Konnick, Kaza.
All right.
Here we go.
Is that Oasis City?
Okay.
Oasis City
Or is Oasis City Gardens?
There you go.
Wait, City Center or Guard?
City, City?
Okay.
Is this one or Gardens?
City?
All right, guys.
Oh my god, it is.
Where are the cars, though?
All right, let's start.
I'm ready.
Where's the...
Okay, wait, wait.
Oh my god, it's right there.
Get out.
Oh, my God.
I made it.
Wait, okay.
We have to start the lobby.
Give me a sec.
Show it up.
Start game mode.
Alright, we start for real.
Here we go.
He is so fun to play.
He really is.
There's just, I don't know.
There's just something about it.
I think he's the best character ever designed.
He really is, chat.
He is literally like peak character design.
And it's just a cat on a jetpack.
It's so fucking stupid.
But yet, but yet it works.
Yet this concept just works.
No, I got him!
I got him!
Design is so good.
I think I wish the eyes were a little I don't like the eyes
though I personally think the eyes could be better oh my god
I see you get over here that's right I picked up a med kit
oh my god everyone's just everyone's farming for it no the
third party we just need cosplay the dark to come out at
marvel and then it'll be no you think you can hide there
what are you doing little guy i saw you trying to hide there
oh 15 kills to win he doesn't know he doesn't jump oh shit
okay that's right make it no i did it
back at least i'm almost close up I can throw a cat in the
traffic.
Come on.
Oh, he wants to use the...
Oh, that's right.
My med kit.
Get over here.
Oh!
I
did!
He went in the traffic!
I got him in the end.
I don't know if you saw it, but I actually got him in the
end.
He's cat bat.
There we go.
Nice.
These combat's looking really weird.
It's looking real different.
Okay.
The fuel recharges so fast, by the way.
Oh my god, it's not me!
Take him to the car!
He was close.
He almost got it.
He actually almost got it.
Oh, I see you.
You have to take the fight closer.
You have to bait them in.
Everyone's like fighting near the cars now.
Everyone's just fighting here.
My kill.
Yoink.
What the fuck?
That's cheating.
Oh, no.
No, I'm so close.
Ah, I almost made it.
He's Comcat.
It's raining, cats.
Oh, my God.
He's so close.
Everybody.
Wait.
No, I missed.
He's so lucky.
Oh, shit.
Almost got me.
There you go.
There, I couldn't dodge the melee.
Oh, you missed.
Bitch.
That's fucking right.
You missed.
You didn't grab me.
That's a victory in my book.
Holy shit.
That was like...
Those are...
Did you see that?
All headshots.
I'm getting better at aiming with this.
Bitch, I played Ultron.
I have to play Ultron.
I have to aim in the air.
my oh my god oh my god he fucking flew away like a pussy
because he is a pussy
imagine being a pussy true live like a goddamn cat
that's fucking right
Oh my god, there's like a fucking war here I stole kill
still
Get over here, get over here Get over here Now it's my kill
Oh, I should have played near the car I should have played
near the cars I was foolish
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow Mowmow.
Almost got the kill steal, too.
Got you!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god!
He's trying!
Wait, did you see that?
Oh, my god!
Holy shit!
Double up!
Oh no, one more killed.
Don't let him have it.
I got top four though.
I got top four.
What is this?
The cat.
The car.
I feel that.
What did he do?
Bro!
You kill sealer.
You fucking...
You can kill, steal it.
Holy shit, that's crazy.
That was a crazy game.
That was actually crazy.
I have more Jetpack Cat time.
Back to Jetpack Cat.
Actually, I won't mind.
Let's do damage.
Quick play.
And damage.
Kill, steal of the game.
okay he's fun he's so fucking fun but i feel i i do feel
like it's only on support it's only on quickly the moment
people figure out how to play rank against this cat it's not
no longer gonna be fun i don't think it'll be fun after that
all right onrun or or emra Which one, guys?
Enjoy it while it lasts.
That's why I'm joining it now.
I'm enjoying it now, guys.
Anra?
Now arriving at Lee Jong-un.
Alright.
John Halo or Anra?
Yeah, John Halo or Anra.
It's so stupid.
He's so funny.
all right she's so crazy Josh I think like a good DPS can
like I'd be really scared to play I think I'd be really
scared to play against her in rank for sure are they all in
rank too guys are they because usually when it's new
characters they would like give like a one week trial one
week or two week period but already now are they all
automatically in rank are
they I don't know if I want to use up my thing.
My shift charges fast, though, I will say.
What the fuck is she here?
Oh my god, it's Talon time.
Yeah, bro, that's...
Where is she?
I have to think so much when I play her though i will say
that she requires me to actually think really hard
there you go
holy i have to use my brain so much oh my it's because i
have to there's like so much movement and stuff too and that
to be aware of she is so really okay
Oh, so fast
She felt oh so yeah, I have to lock in for her like I
literally can't talk when I'm playing her because like She
requires so much concentration in general
Like So much damage come on What's my other DPS doing?
I swear I was I felt like I was doing a lot of damage.
Oh my god.
I couldn't control it That's unlucky.
Okay, I like it.
I felt I was doing so much damage.
I'm like, seriously, it was like, what the fuck?
What am I out of DPS doing?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I just think so much!
Like, please, please heal me.
Please heal me.
Oh my god, why would you all there?
oh my god the fact that this is why would you take it why
would you take the
help what my team she needed it more don't why did he take
it oh my god is i'm literally like trying so hard this tank
was so fucking greedy our other dps is not picking up the
slack i will say i will say he is one three right now you
could help me ward off evil she was missing 25 hp
that's crazy he's like he's like oh no i'm not 100 hp my
health fact i say is i'm like on my deathbed but please sir
i this is the cure the cure for my real my my terminal
disease i'm gonna try to flank i feel like she's like a
flank character too if i play it correctly
what the is that shield
there we go Fucking easy
Oh my god Easy Actually easy Oh my god Actually I feel like
I have to make plays for her
I actually have to make like plays If I want to play her
Alright Come on out of this
But my team's dead i didn't think my team was gonna die that
fast but okay
i missed all the point i thought i was gonna do a flake and
then my entire team died i i was like all right guys i got
the flake and then they the other team just hard push so
fast fine anyways i feel like
There we go.
Oh my god.
I have to grab this.
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
My back hurts!
My back actually hurts right now.
Like with the amount of fucking plays I'm doing for this.
Holy shit.
There you go.
I'm actually like playing the game of the century right now.
I have to...
Oh, that's fine.
I got this.
I'm fine with that.
Holy shit, please!
Oh my
god, please!
Holy shit!
My back!
My fucking back!
I'm literally fucking doing so much.
I think, like, for her, she's definitely a flanker, for
sure.
Like, I have to flank with her.
Play her correctly.
For now.
This is how I feel when I'm playing her, honestly.
No.
Fuck.
Everybody just used every up.
Just kill me.
Oh my god.
The cat just needed to heal me.
The cat.
to heal me okay i think they can they could go without me my
back hurts so much
i don't think we're winning this there's nothing no way we
need the touch point and i don't have a rush yep i'm back 16
kills man
Oh my god.
I literally did so much.
I didn't even try.
Like, look at that!
That's insane.
Like, she's so crazy.
She actually is.
My team was...
My team did not help much.
I had to do everything.
oh that's crazy though she's fun i have to say she is fun to
play she's not fun i don't think she's gonna be fun to play
against um the fact that i could do all of that as someone
that has no experience on anon run imagine like imagine how
fucking um how fucking hard how fucking strong she is with
an actual dps player yeah like an actual dps player players
go fucking destroy people the fact that I had no experience
on her it's been a while since I played DPS I feel like
she's just absolutely broken for now from what I've been
playing she feels really broken I didn't I did enjoy playing
her I just know that in rank it's gonna be hell hmm for sure
I'm I like her I like her playstyle
She does so much damage too It's crazy Like the shift E left
click right click You either like maybe like left click
right click Shift E and then left click right click It's so
much the damage is insane And then I could shift twice too I
never tried a revival I always been using it as like a I've
been using it as like Engage every time.
Compared to...
Can I play...
I'm DPSK.
Everybody wants to be Jetpack Cat.
I'm creating support after this.
Everyone wants to be...
Well, I'm voting this.
That's right.
I want to escort Dorado.
Oh, I like how there's Talon...
Like, Talon flags on here now.
Jetpack Cat is fun to play as a support, but...
That's right.
I haven't.
I have an SSD.
I got in first.
I still, I personally am not.
I think the only character I don't think it's fun to play is
Mizuki.
Mizuki is like meh for me.
Mizuki is meh.
I think it sucks though.
I feel like the port has a really nice mobility, has really
nice mobility, but Mizuki does not.
Like, I feel like if anything, Mizuki would need a wall
clap.
Mizuki doesn't have, like, uh, like, does it have, like, the
best mobility.
Yeah, I played Domina.
I played Domina, and then I got counter-picked, and then I
was, and then I played Maga for the first time.
But I don't think, I don't find it like that fun.
Oh.
Wait, is Lifeline?
Does Lifeline heal as well?
Well, I don't want it.
Yeah.
Wait, I don't want it.
I don't want it no more.
There
we go.
John Hatem!
Get the cat!
That's right!
Grab the cat!
What the fuck?
It's Call of Duty and Halo?
What is this?
There we go.
I don't remember which one I liked.
I think it was this, right?
What the fuck?
There's no...
Why would you play Farah against me?
That is like...
okay it's also clicks by the way if you want to know um if
you want to know the all is also click so you can actually
there you go oh shit there was a pharaoh okay you better
kill her
okay let's try that again her his movement is crazy with the
shift though i will there um his all is also like you can
click it
but i can break this or just sheer clicks okay i need heals
though
oh oh my
god all right oh no not the cat What the fuck?
I'm leaving.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm fucking leaving.
That's too suborbital.
Oh, no.
Our widow's dead.
I can help her, though.
Okay.
There we go.
Whoops.
Wait, I...
Wait, there's...
Rocket jumps with it.
Wait, okay.
I did not realize that
All right, see I it's also clicked by the
What is this stick on contact area?
Yeah, there's Nate jumps.
I did you see that I may jump there
Yeah You can nade jump from it.
Yeah, see?
There's nade jumps.
I tested that to test it out.
I wanted to test out the nade jump.
And yeah, you can actually nade jump.
He really is John Halo, guys.
Oh, Widow's so fucking dead.
Alright.
There we go.
It was worth it.
It's fine.
I almost got it I almost got oh my god he's monkey down his
counter swapping so hard
oh my god try so hard to save his life I think it worked
there we go protect one
are you fucking kidding me not the train
all right i should have waited until the all is gone to be
fair oh my god i should have i really wanted i thought i
could kill him for some reason
holy shit okay like no awareness at all
actually no awareness for this widow
what the fuck like what's the plan
worth it worth it I'm carrying quick grab the monkey grab
him
oh my god 31 to 19 look at my teeth It can be versus my
team.
It can be versus any enemy team.
Bro.
John Halo reporting for duty.
Grab the monkey.
Just grab him.
Bro.
10k damage.
That's insane.
He has doubled everyone.
That's actually...
Okay, now it's time.
It's shit.
It's time.
Get packed, cat.
Holy shit.
My fucking back.
My back.
I gotta see.
Well, don't see a chiropractor.
There's scams.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if you're a chiropractor.
If your occupation is a chiropractor.
But I personally see chiropracting as a scam.
Because like too many horror stories.
Too many horror stories.
it yeah apparently it's not it is not even a long-term fix
like it could actually fuck up your body forever if you do
it if like one wrong stretch uh what one wrong stretch can
make you paralyzed and that's a fucking fear that's that's a
fear how
it moves like don't worry
it cannot guarantee that'll fix your back and can
potentially cause you to be paralyzed so like i don't i
don't fuck with that new phobia unlock you see if you never
get if you never go to a chiropractor you'll never have to
experience it yeah short-term fix long-term damage
apparently i feel like a lot of characters a lot of the new
characters seem
seem really over tuned except for Mizuki.
Or maybe I just didn't know how to play her.
I just didn't know how to play it.
But for now, it seems like everybody is like super strong.
And then there's Mizuki who's like, who seems to be the most
balanced character out of all four of all five of them.
Mizuki seems to be the most balanced one out of five of
them.
Everyone else seems super over tuned.
in quick play in quick play i feel like a really good player
who plays mizuki will absolutely destroy people but like in
quick play since everybody is like learning right now he
feels the most balanced until until like people figured him
out oh oh they finally tweeted it out i'm in
it out, guys, about the Marvel Rivals preview.
What are... We're all so surprised.
I don't know what team I'm in, though.
Let me check.
I don't know.
Let me see if they announced the teams.
Alright, let's see.
Let me check the...
I'm going to check the document to see if I know what team
I'm in.
Alright.
What What the fuck?
Okay.
I am...
Oh, wait.
I'm on Tim's team.
It's me, Samju, Guru, J3, Malaya, and Tim.
Enemy team is Puffer, Bougar, Emmeroo, Flats, Moxie, and
Gale.
No they split us.
I've been playing against Moxie all the time now.
no gale time that thing is when they split us us up gale was
first place guys we broke the curse but then he got to be
first place in the last tournament i got i got third right i
got third but like he got first he broke
the curse even stronger we have two tank play oh we do Guru
and Tim.
I have Guru, Tim, Songju, and Jade.
Wait, I got...
Oh, wait.
I don't need to pick yet.
Ah, but then, like, we have the...
The... Moxie's just gonna play Hawkeye.
He's just gonna play Hawkeye.
I don't want to play against Moxie.
I hate playing against Hawkeye.
We can't...
We can't ban Hawkeye.
It's no bad.
regardless
Yeah Jetpack cat Oh
my god, wait, what?
Jetpack cat Does anyone
Hello, would anyone like to be gripped?
Yeah!
Hello, who would like to be gripped right now?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I should heal.
Where's their jetpack cat, though?
Go, well, I got you!
Okay, not like that, though.
I heal the best I could.
I'm healing.
Oh, my God.
I am healing right now.
Hey, guys.
I'm doing my best.
I'm healing.
Boom!
Oh, my God.
I think I actually killed somebody.
Oh, shit.
Where's my...
Where's my tank?
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to hit.
Boom!
Get out of here.
Okay, I can't do it.
I can't help you with that.
Don't worry.
Does anyone want to be gripped?
That's our get her!
Get her!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait, where do I even fucking take these guys?
Oh, we lost it.
This is a terrible map for...
That's it!
Boom!
Get over here!
Get over here, Lucio!
Get out of here!
Okay, I'm leaving.
Alright, where am I going?
Okay.
Do this.
I got you.
Oh my god, worth it!
Worth it!
So worth it!
My entire team's dead.
My entire team died.
But like, it was worth it.
Honestly.
My entire team died, but it was worth it.
I literally soloed that fucking idiot.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
Let me go.
Does anyone want to be picked up?
Anyone?
No?
Okay, that's cool.
I don't know how to do it correctly anyway.
To be fair, I am not doing that.
Oh.
That's okay.
I got you.
Boom!
I used my melee to heal.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's okay.
Get away!
No!
I did that.
Oh, no!
He freaking took me down.
That's okay.
Oh, I got you guys.
I got you.
you guys.
I need you guys to get in, though.
Oh my god, not me.
No, not me.
Oh, this is not good for us.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
No!
I survived for so long.
Lost.
Look, I think...
I think...
DPS diff.
Just a DPS diff, you know?
I am healing.
Okay, maybe not as much.
It's not fair!
They ran Lucio!
They're running Lucio.
They're not trying new characters.
Jesus.
Get...
Oh!
Get C9!
That's fucking right.
I cancelled this up!
Get cat!
That's right!
Oh my god, get Ajax!
Clearly God is up cancelled.
I had a feeling he was gonna do that.
That's called Game Sense.
Guys, he got Game Sense.
I forgot like support bro okay he's fucking oh no oh
god well I got you I got you that's right boom get cat boom
boom get cat what you gonna do huh what you gonna do run run
I don't know how to grip my teammates still.
I don't know how to do it.
I don't know how to do it in, like, an actual, helpful way.
That cat's a killer.
Oh, my God.
I grip.
Oh, shit.
I'm leaving.
Oh, fuck.
He actually shot the split.
cat he actually shot the flying cat I didn't think he'd
actually do it guys I didn't think he'd actually do it there
you go he looked up they didn't look up for so long.
I think I'll honor DC'd.
I think she DC'd.
Guys, I don't think I think it's a five.
Oh my god, that's it!
There we go.
They have no tank!
They threw!
They actually threw.
Oh my god, he's shooting up.
He's actually go shooting Hager.
Okay, our on-run is crazy, though.
Like, why would you do that?
Oh my god, our DPS is special!
Oh my god, my tank is dead.
Don't worry, I'll kidnap later.
I'll kidnap later.
Why would she do that?
She was, like, so low.
So, well, we have another on-rush.
That's weird that they're starting to look up.
I don't like it.
I don't like that he's looking up, guys.
Get over here.
Get...
No!
Oh, my God.
Worth it.
Oh my god.
I'm so good at DPS still on the cat.
Okay.
I'll pre-heal him.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
That's a little...
What the fuck already?
I did not expect him to have it already.
Oh my god, that's right Get clawed Get clawed Oh, I built
all so fast though Get clawed
I think the claw is pretty strong Not gonna lie The claw
feels strong What the fuck?
How did he kill him?
The cloud feels strong overall.
IMO.
Oh my god, wait.
Worth it, worth it, worth it, worth it, worth it, worth it.
Shit, I'm so good at the cat.
literally bone rush what can they do what can they do that's
just cat on a jetpack what the fuck can they do what they
actually don't know what to do it's a fucking cat on a
jetpack oh my god I'm so sad he faded out he actually faded
out out.
He fucking did it.
He faded out.
God.
I didn't expect it.
Oh my God, it's worth it.
Oh my God.
Did you see that tech?
Wait, I carried so hard.
That is insane.
Yeah.
real this cat I'm fucking figuring out that new meta the cat
meta guys I feel all so fast too by the way but I actually
build off extremely fast faster than I should oh
no that's unlucky I don't know is unlucky because get
of here
i got you lucio i got you i you carried away that's just i
got him like four times bye lucio goodbye
julia can't believe i found the front I found him
Yeah, I was like Goodbye, Lucio
Removing Yeah, I removed the enemy healer Now I want to be
one Holy shit No, I told you I removed myself as well I also
removed Myself Oh my god, he's so fun He's had actually so
fun.
I think the most impressive was I, I canceled the Lucio alt
with my grab.
I think that was crazy.
I, I think that was insane.
The fact that I was able to cancel the Lucio, the Lucio alt
was crazy.
I don't understand why I can't see my match.
Oh my God, what is, is this?
It was this.
Which one was this?
It's actually my 1v1.
It's like, I picked you to 1v1 me.
Get over here.
You're next.
His fuel recharge is insane.
Why can't I look at...
What the fuck?
Why can't I look at my history?
I want to see it.
I want to see that game.
That's crazy.
I can't even look...
They didn't... I don't know what happened to the history,
guys.
Here comes the claw.
Yeah, I am in the game reports.
It's nothing.
It says I haven't played a single game.
I didn't play a single game, guys.
No, it's not even there.
It doesn't exist.
It's like I never play it.
Does it truly exist?
Did it really happen?
the game never took note of it i wonder i don't know i don't
know if like all right let's do uh all right guys what
should we play i'll do one lg chat what do we do one lg the
small indica it was all just a dream
Tank, DPS, or support?
Domina?
Alright.
We ended with Domina.
I saw like more Domina.
Alright.
I'm gonna get water.
Here we go.
Domina time.
Havana.
Alright.
Havana time.
Here we go.
The perfect world is shaped by my hand.
I don't know what the fuck to do with the grip.
I always wanted to retire.
Like, I don't know.
I feel like maybe I think the grip would be fun if you're
coordinating it with like some a friend or something.
If you're coordinating with a team in rank, like I have grip
me.
Sorry, geez, you're flying the way you are.
Okay.
Let's see.
600.
Okay.
All right.
Maybe even in one piece Here we go
Let's go
The monkey Why are you here?
What the fuck is going on?
That's right, I see you over there
Guys, I need a little help here.
Alright.
Oh, tank is so boring.
Tank.
Tank is.
Push!
Oh my god, okay.
That was actually crazy.
Look at that.
That was insane counter, guys.
That was actually crazy.
That was much fun Much more fun I agree I
agree Fight oh shit sorry I pushed him closer to you That's
my bad I pushed him closer That's my bad that.
Oh, they're on Genji now.
That's crazy.
Oh, man.
Try to...
Wait.
I didn't realize I have to aim the ult.
I...
I thought the ult auto.
Okay.
To be fair, I thought the ult auto tracks i didn't realize i
actually have to aim the ult that's that's an oopsie that's
actually an oopsie from me oh that's unlucky that's unlucky
yeah the aoe i thought the aoe auto aims
bro i swear to god you make me play diva i swear i just want
to play that's the thing that's what people they all these
people are like counter these people are like not picking
the new characters to have fun they're all like counter
picking like same with that get out of that bubble holy shit
you out of here there
we go there we go
holy shit Yeah, I know it's counter watch, but also, fuck
that guy.
But also, I want to try to shiny new characters.
Get out of here!
Oh my god.
This guy, she's crazy for going.
We're going so close.
Get in there!
Oh my god, and I got caged.
And I got caged too.
I feel like I have to play.
Did you guys see they released new heroes today?
The enemy team only, there's only the...
Bro, I stare like, guys, did you see that?
So true Did you see
Must have missed that Even they're like They're like yeah
guys, you know, there's new characters guys Oh wasted that
That's funny, though.
Oh, no.
Our honor is dead as fuck.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
I killed him.
I got him.
Who is...
Who are you getting shot at by?
I can't tell.
I hear somber.
Yeah.
Oh,
I can't help them there.
I mean, I can.
Oh, my God.
I can't push.
It's fine.
There we are.
Worth it.
Push.
I mean, it's good counter.
I will say.
I'm counter-diving the Winston.
When I'm there, I have to play with my team, though.
Push!
Oh, shit.
I fell down.
I'm sorry.
Like, where do I put the shield for?
Like, here, I'm gonna...
Get out of here!
Oh, my God.
Whoa.
I mean, okay.
Oh What the fuck
I'll fucking kill this guy
What oh my god here he is
There we go I was like what is going on?
I'm so There we go It's like Yeah most damage Look at that.
My entire team are playing new characters.
And the enemy team went and tried to play meta.
Or play their best character.
Holy shit.
Look at John Halo.
Girl, this has to be the easiest character in the game.
I'm sorry.
John Halo.
It has to be the easiest character.
character.
I say Domina.
She does her job.
She is also, she seems balanced.
She seems really balanced.
I don't know.
Her alt is like pretty ass.
I think it's stronger when everyone's bunched up.
I was playing against a dive.
For some reason, I was playing against a dive team and then
I don't know what to do against it.
I think we're playing bra.
Yeah.
I think playing if i'm playing against bra then like her all
it would be super strong but like she's really good at
anti-dive i liked it i literally canceled the anti-dive with
my push
but i think she's strong against anti i think she's strong
against dive and um she does she's boring i will say i think
i find her boring to play i think she's not fun to play like
she's just like shield shield push when enemy comes in, E,
and when they're closer, but like, I personally think, like,
I don't know, I think she's like, she's pretty boring to
play.
I don't think she's not, she doesn't seem like fun in terms
of, like, she does get the job done, but I'm not having,
like, the most fun playing here compared to the other
characters.
I had fun playing Aaron, I had fun playing Emra, I had fun
playing Jetpack Cat, I was very lost playing Mizuki, but I
can see that he can't be strong in the right hands.
He seems really balanced with he's good.
I think a really good, like, flex support player can play
Mizuki really, really well because he's, I think his damage
seems pretty good in general, especially if you're really
good at damage.
You're really good at damage and you can build up your heals
from it.
But yeah, it was really fun getting back to Overwatch,
honestly.
I had a really great time revisiting Overwatch.
With all the five new heroes, Jetpack has so fucking fun i
wish we could watch the replay guys i but like unfortunately
for some reason the replay replays are dead right now but i
want to say most fun character 100 jetpack cat like
especially the last game i played with him where i was just
fucking running around like scratching people and and like
abducting them and having my own one v one like i kidnapped
him and be like one v one me no items final destination uh
cat only I literally abducted the Lucille like four times.
He had a health pack, too.
He literally used the health pack and still lost.
Anyway, that is my personal opinion on Overwatch.
Tomorrow is Rivals.
It'll be on Twitch tomorrow.
I'll post the schedule later today for those who want to
know the schedule.
Thank y'all for coming.
It was very early stream, but I feel like we had a lot of
fun.
definitely enjoyed all the new characters that they
implemented.
As, oh, I hope you guys enjoyed watching, too.
It's been a while since I played Overwatch, but, um, it was
really fun, uh, checking out all the new updates and
everything.
And we're gonna check out new updates and rivals, too,
tomorrow.
I swear, like, all the games are getting updated this week.
It's crazy.
Like, they all realized, it's like, they are, they're all,
like, in their own fucking Hunger Games or some shit.
They're, like, Overwatch came out with an update.
Rivals are coming up with an update.
update speak of apex my skin is uh officially uh up on the
apex on apex legends so if you want to get the doki skin um
on apex right now it's free you just have to complete
challenges it is officially up on the on the game the seven
anniversary and another thing um the watson plus is also
officially up so uh there is four weeks to pre-order it uh
you can grab the uh watson merch right the watch official
watson plushy uh and everything so uh yeah thank you guys
thank you all for watching as always everybody stay hydrated
oh yeah and deadlock also updated but like deadlock i still
have i have to learn that game i haven't installed it yet
since the last time we played deadlock on stream which was
like a year plus ago um but um but like it's honestly um lot
of fun um and uh yeah a lot of games are getting a lot of
fucking updates now and what else do i want to say um
there's something else i wanted to say too fuck it already
already left my head um oh yeah i felt really bad for 2x ko
because i heard they like like cut half their staff like
yesterday or two days ago because they didn't get the
reception they anticipated for a riot game apparently i
don't know if you guys heard they cut like half their staff
for it so um so i thought it was like really unfortunate
because it seemed like a lot of love was put into that game
but they just um right now everyone's just playing mobas
again i think like everyone's now just playing i think a new
meta is literally a moba meta at the moment
um anyway as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
Get up and move around to get that blow forward.
And you say it for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.